To one,
yes,
yes.
Trevor,
we're here.
We're back to two years,
almost to the day.
And we didn't even plan it that way.
Know it was weird.
I was,
I pulled it up and I'm like,
oh,
hey,
I was here in 2014.
Wasn't October Shit,
October 23rd and in two years
something's happened to your beard where
it's a bright yellow that doesn't exist
in nature or it exists in flowers,
flowers.
Uh,
it,
it reacts under black light as well.
Oh yeah.
My twitter profile pictures under black
light.
Um,
yeah.
I used to dye my beard crazy fucking
colors all the time.
It was like green,
purple and blue and all that.
And uh,
I did this neon yellow and I've always
liked it.
And the girl I was dating always hated
it.
Perfect.
So yeah,
run with it.
It's my,
uh,
my vengeance.
Does this crazy shirt you go onto,
was this ms dot atonic university,
you know,
a could Fulu HP lovecraft.
Yeah.
Uh,
this company does it.
Well,
they're called Geeky jerseys and they do
just radical fucking jersey.
So this is like the Cafe Lulu Jersey and
it's like a wizard Jersey to look,
look at the sleeves,
the hockey sleeves,
so it's legit.
Hockey sleeve goalie cuts a little bit
Baggier I thought you're all wizard.
I know they do stuff like a,
they've got like a game of thrones
jerseys and all this crazy stuff and
they were just like,
hey,
you do a lot of talks and you always
wear a jersey so we're just gonna start
sending you yours.
And I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Well that's very nice of them because I
always wear a hockey jersey.
When I was in here I was trying to be
last time professional with the Polo and
all that.
Oh yeah,
he was that because you are promoting
something.
You had to be.
Yeah,
I had to be a little bit more clean cut.
It was like Nat Geo,
like a mandate there.
Are they giving you like,
like standards of dress and stuff?
Not really,
but since it was like a pretty
professional documentary,
we were doing a,
it was suggested very lightly by my
publicist and she's just like,
well,
you know,
business casual,
maybe business.
I'm like,
but I were hockey jerseys in short.
She's like,
yeah,
no.
Oh,
why not?
That's why I'm doing it now.
Mad.
Isn't it funny?
It's like you're a legitimate
paleontologists.
You actually do real research.
Like why?
Why?
Why do you have to dress like everybody
knows your credentials?
Like the thing about that,
the crazy thing is,
I mean there's the whole Paleo thing
too.
It's weird when you ask somebody,
hey,
is like,
do you know what a paleontologist is?
A lot of people say yes.
A lot of people go,
Hey Ross on friends.
What's Ross on?
Oh,
I forgot he was a paleontologist.
Bull shitty was.
I know,
right fucking due to all that free time
hanging out in a coffee shop talking
about nonsense.
I know.
I know like our one position guys at
museums that doing like full academics,
they would never have that amount of
time.
No time.
No zero a fucked.
It's crazy.
You can't be a casual paleontologist.
Right.
And I asked them,
what is a paleontologist look like?
When I used to work at the tar pits,
I would ask like,
kids on tours and stuff like that.
And they're like,
oh,
he's got like a hat and a whip.
I'm like,
they're describing Indiana Jones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's why you were right.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
and I'm like,
okay,
well I have a neon orange beard and I'm
wearing a lab coat and I'm covered in
tattoos.
Do you think I'm apparently there and
you know,
you're like a biker and here's,
here's the stuff.
Welcome to my lab.
This is my deal going on.
You can get away with that in 2016.
But if you were living in the 19
seventies,
good luck.
Oh,
I would be burned at the metaphorical
stake.
Wouldn't have worked.
No,
it's like because I had long hair and
died.
Weird colors.
You know,
it's funny,
Dude.
You,
uh,
you know,
like I said,
you're a legit paleontologists,
but I saw you the other day arguing with
flat earth people on twitter.
I'm also a science generalists.
Like,
Holy Shit,
dude,
you going to war?
It was hilarious.
I checked back an hour later,
you're still going at it because you
threw it out there.
And I'm like,
okay,
I see where this is going.
Someone was calling me a flat earth sell
out.
The guy was calling me a sellout because
uh,
because I,
I make fun of flat earth.
And he's like,
I know where your checks being cashed.
Like what I'm getting around Earth.
Like,
hey,
keep a secret right around earth check.
Here's the shill organization.
Imagine if like everybody in the media
was just getting a check to make sure
that you keep,
just keep perpetrating the lie that the
earth is round,
like the logic behind that,
but it's not just fucking flatter and
flatter.
And Chem trails and creationism and moon
hoaxers and the reptilians have just all
the weird shit man.
Speaking of trade one is the craziest
one.
Like,
like everything is round except the
earth.
Is that what you're saying?
Like all the videos have all been faked.
Every one of them.
Every space station mission that took
video.
Every space shuttle mission that God
video,
every satellite that gets photographed
on it's fake,
all of it's everything from,
from the beginning of the 19 sixties
when they first started doing this to
today.
So fake.
Yeah.
So I've actually gotten a huge fucking
debates about that.
Like,
oh,
like people on twitter live and online.
Well,
and there was one person a cap.
What was his name?
Uh,
he came in,
he came into the bar that I bartend at
now and he was talking about it briefly
and he's like,
yeah,
you know,
uh,
I heard you on the Joe Rogan program and
it was really cool and you know,
he's like,
not really cool with conspiracy
theorists and all that.
I'm like,
no,
he gives them like equal time.
He's like,
yeah,
the whole flat earth thing.
I'm like,
don't even start,
man.
He was serious.
Yeah.
It's these fucking youtube videos.
That's what it is.
You watch youtube videos and no one's
opposing them while they're talking to.
They're talking very.
They're,
they sound very articulate.
They using all these big words and
they're saying things without anybody
go,
what?
Stop.
That's not true,
and that's the problem and I both them
and science at the same time.
How do you blame science will a long
time ago when we had guys like Richard
Hoagland doing the face on Mars and
crazy shit like that,
um,
or like early creationists are flood
geology or flatter things way in the way
in the back of,
you know,
in the backwards time,
like science would always like shoved
off into a corner and go,
hey,
see the cranks over there.
Let's ignore them.
If we ignore them,
they'll go away.
And then we got things like compuserve
and AOL and forums and bbss and then
they got a little louder than they got
access to self publishing.
They got a little louder now with social
media,
Youtube and all that.
The same five percent of humanity can
get really fucking loud.
We didn't shut them down early enough
and now they're loud enough that we have
a problem.
Well,
Hoagland,
out of his fucking mind.
I watched a whole lecture where he was
talking about all of the artificial
structures on the moon and this guy just
arbitrarily measures the distance
between this rock and the point of this
period of it.
It's not a pyramid,
but he would call it a pyramid,
right?
The district.
This is exactly the same distance as the
pyramid in Giza.
The connection to the left foot of the
sphinx and like,
how do you.
What?
Why,
why?
Why are you making that connection that
you could do that anywhere.
You could just,
you could do,
you could overlay.
You could do a map of a city and just
start the.
The distance between your house and my
house is exactly the same as my house to
that rock.
Oh yeah.
That rock holds special significance.
Yeah.
It's like,
oh,
your house is on a Ley line and minds
off that,
right?
It's like,
no,
just stop.
It was madness.
I watched this whole.
It was more than an hour long and I was
watching all these ridiculous
connections that this guy was making and
trying to say that all these structures
that the odds of them being,
you know,
some sort of a natural,
and I'm looking at him like,
that looks like a fucking rock to me.
Yeah.
And he was saying there's,
without a doubt,
that is an artificially created
structure.
Absolutely made by intelligent life
that,
that was the thing with the whole face
on Mars when,
uh,
the Mars reconnaissance orbiter started
doing the flyovers and then he was
getting loud,
or why aren't you going to photograph
the site?
Don't in planes,
blah,
blah.
And they're fine.
Fine.
You know what?
Fuck it.
We're re,
we're redirecting the satellite.
We're going to do eight passes,
high res photos,
the whole deal.
And like,
oh look,
it's a mountain dew.
Cool look.
And it's Rad looking mountain.
It's weird.
It's got a weird shape on the bottom.
The,
the,
what's interesting to me,
far more interesting in the face because
the face was cool in the first picture
because of the shadows and it kind of
almost looked at a face and it was also
a low risk picture from Viking and then
when they got high res pictures you go,
Oh,
well it's just a trick of the shadows
and everything.
What's kind of interesting is what does
happen sometimes in nature.
You get these bizarre shapes almost
looks like someone built it,
like it's kind of on both sides is
parallel lines.
The way it's shaped,
it's almost like a creative piece,
but look at,
look at the hexagonal cleavage at devils
post pile or the giant's causeway in
Scotland and stuff like that.
That looks like it's set in.
That's just because it's hexagonal
cleavage or that one spot on Jupiter.
You know that one spot on the top of
Jupiter,
the top is the status of the hexagon
because of sheer winds.
Amazing.
I talked to a friend that works at jpl
and I'm like,
what is going on here?
It's like,
oh,
there's different densities of air and
sheer winds and it creates this cool
hexagon.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
I mean it's as.
It's a base intelligent base.
The same guy who puts out this video's
about the flat earth now has a video
that you will love and it's dinosaurs
are not real,
which is right up your alley.
Oh,
great.
I didn't know that you were,
uh,
also,
um,
you're not just a flat earth Shill,
but you are also a dinosaur show.
Oh yeah.
I'm,
I'm a dinosaur.
She'll a around show a globe earth
shill.
I worked for chem trail corporations.
Yeah.
All these.
If you could just tell us what is the
purpose of the chem trails?
What are they trying to do?
It depends on who's talking because
they've had like 19 different fucking
stories.
It's like one,
it's like mind control.
The second one is population control.
The third one is solar radiation
management to,
you know,
to either make global warming or to stop
global warming and they fight with each
other.
All it is,
is bullshit.
One hundred percent fucking bullshit.
It's,
you can download a is the same link that
you re tweeted out with the,
with the,
when we did the chem trail back and
forth on twitter.
Um,
you can get a humidity chart of every
day to your location,
gives you the range of humidity into the
stratosphere.
And you know,
when a plane we'll have a contrail will
have a persistent contrail and won't
have anything.
It's home fucking citizen's science.
That can be done.
Yeah.
I mean NASA has a website where they
predict contracts.
They're super accurate.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I've,
I've ripped people apart with this and
then all of a sudden it's like where you
go from now.
So you're now.
So she'll,
well you're arguing with 15 year olds
probably.
There's a lot of it.
Some of her.
Oh,
speaking of controls.
I got this for you.
What is it?
Team Kentrell baby.
Oh,
nice.
Team chem trail.
Spray and pray and pray on and off.
There's an on and off button.
Put this on my car.
People are going to key it.
Going to be mad fucking chill.
It's um,
it's a weird world.
We live in.
Trevor.
To weird world,
there's this access to self publishing,
whether it's youtube or blogs or
podcasts.
You don't need anybody to tell you like,
hey man,
we just ran a check on your information.
Your data's all wrong.
You could just do it to the dinosaur
one.
This guy made this fucking video about
dinosaurs not being real.
I'm like,
this is God damned hilarious
is that.
I think I just.
And it's so.
My whole involvement with this on
twitter is all take that Darwin's fault.
I'd started failing in Darwin.
The,
the twitter handle.
Yeah.
It's a great twitter handle.
Take the Darwin.
He has spawned an entire fucking like
nest of people.
Take that earth theory,
fail that whenever somebody says,
oh,
evolution is just a theory,
he jumps in,
take that salt for vaccines.
Um,
take that for skin,
for like for circumcision.
There's like,
take that science.
He's the general one.
Take that etymology.
She just does words that people fuck up.
This whole group,
he spawned this,
this just psychology,
science communication.
Hey,
look at the specimen idiots.
There's like 30 of them and there's also
a take that dinosaurs that does all the
dinosaur retreating.
They really are,
is a growing movement where people don't
think dinosaurs were real well.
So it was like last year or the year
before.
I think it was maybe may have been right
after I did the show last time there was
a,
there was this bogus group that started
a facebook thing called Christians
against dinosaurs and they put pictures
of a protest and all of their like,
oh no,
it's big Paleo,
like,
are you fucking kidding?
It was a total hoax.
So it was like an onion type deal.
Exactly.
Parody.
But they started to run with it and just
like have a fun time.
They found me and a couple other
paleontologists on twitter than I
noticed their entire protest photo was
actually photo shopped from a parking,
uh,
parking protest I think in Scotland
because there's this one fun little
graphic of like no feathered dinosaurs
that paleontologist came up with because
we're just crazy people and they use
that graphic.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
And so I found all the artifacts and
photoshop and I called them out on them
and they just got real quiet real fast.
There's a big debate about whether or
not dinosaurs had feathers,
right?
Um,
yeah,
but it depends on the dinosaur.
So sort of like depends on lizard
versus.
Depends on the bird,
right?
Right.
Many dinosaurs,
uh,
either have evidence of feathers or they
are morphologically similar to dinosaurs
with feathers.
I'm like raptors,
we have found a feather imprints.
There's the quill knobs on the owner
where the wings would be and we have
found theropods the beast footed
dinosaurs with feathers.
Whether or not they all did is the
question,
did tyrannosaurs have feathers?
Not quite sure yet.
Likely maybe as a baby.
And then when it grew up,
but I don't know,
it could be a 14 foot long.
Chicken is a,
um,
uh,
a replica of a dinosaur.
I forget which dinosaur.
I think it's a raptor and it's at the
university or the Museum of Bozeman,
Bozeman,
Montana.
And they have this feather dinosaur up
on display.
It's really kind of interesting because
one half of it,
they have a kind of split down the
middle of one,
half of it is covered in feathers and
the other half of it you just see the
actual bones itself.
Oh,
that's cool.
Like,
like that old invisible,
invisible human that we had to put
together like in the,
in the eighties.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Yeah.
See if he could find that Jamie,
because it's pretty cool.
But you know,
they,
they go with all these wild crazy colors
of feathers.
It's like,
it's almost too bad we can't figure out
what they really looked like because
we're just kind of piecing together
their skin texture and just guessing on
the colors.
Every once in a while we'll find
something awesome.
Like,
uh,
there was uh,
the [inaudible] a Hadrosaur Leonardo
that actually had skin and organs that
soft tissue,
that mineralized and all this cool stuff
or feather imprints from archaeopteryx
or I'm like,
interesting.
Looked looking like a beat,
a beat dinosaurs like aqua lops and
stuff.
Really Cool Shit.
But
the problem is,
is just it's fossils are rare doing any
sort of soft tissue preservation is
rare,
extremely rare,
and all the lighter material just Kinda
desiccates and falls away.
So when we find something like that,
it's holy crap,
just shut everything down and focus on
it real quick.
That's the most fascinating thing about
the fossil record to me and said how
difficult it is to actually make a
fossil.
Yeah.
Most things just write,
write,
write it.
It has to be certain,
certain conditions it.
Um,
but most people think,
oh,
it has to be buried in water.
And then like turn in sand covering it
and all that.
Well that's one way.
And that's a very common way.
Like a lot of the stuff in Montana,
a that used to be swamp land with a
western interior seaway.
So dinosaurs like a t rex and
triceratops,
they would get a covered in mud and
sediment,
all that.
And the bones would generalize the
calcium on the outside of the bone would
get replaced with minerals in the water
and the sand.
And then they would get buried in
sandstone.
It's all cool.
But then you've got things that can fall
into peat bogs,
natural trap caves,
tarpits like here in la,
and all sorts of other things that
create fossils which are really cool.
So it's not just mineralization through
water that is hard to do.
It can happen quickly depending on the
limestone,
the amount of limestone in the dripping
you can.
There was somebody that like left a boot
in a heavily limestone water cave and
calcified like in a matter of weeks.
But that's not really mineralization
that's more like encasement.
But yeah,
fossils are fossils are rare.
To do a fossil is rare that the concept
I think also alludes people.
Most people when they see a fossil bone,
they think that that's the bone itself,
just really old.
And what it is is the minerals have
replaced the bone in the actual shape of
the bone.
I tried to explain that to a friend of
mine who had a mega don tooth,
you know,
he's saying this is a megalodon tooth.
And I said,
well,
it's a fossil of a mega non tooth.
I go,
it's not really the tooth anymore.
None of the tooth remains.
It's just the shape of the tooth.
He's like,
no,
I bought it.
It's a megalodon tooth.
I'm like,
it's.
But you notice how it's black,
like they don't have black teeth.
Yeah.
See,
that's one side of it.
And then the other side of it,
you can see it like that.
It's got like a punk rock hairdo and
shit.
Crazy face.
It's pretty dope.
I've,
I've seen that.
I've seen,
I've actually used the opposite photo in
a talk.
Um,
because it looks like they're humping.
Yeah.
From one angle.
And uh,
I have,
I have it.
Yep.
There it is.
I've used that.
I have a talk called that's not a
fucking dinosaur.
And I opened up with images of dinosaurs
fucking um,
just because you have to do that just to
be fun.
Just to be fun.
Yeah.
That,
that is a cool one with the long hair
and yeah,
it kind of looks like the seventies
dinosaur and it's like,
it used to be a roadie for like van
Halen and the eighties and that kind of
thing.
The skid row dinosaur.
What's a crazy looking shape and when
you see all those colors,
but again,
it's just an artistic interpretation,
right?
We don't know and that's the thing.
We get a lot of flack for that and was
like,
how do you know it looked like that.
We don't.
We know.
We know how the bones go together.
We know where the muscle points are so
we can figure out the girth of the
muscle,
the connection points,
and then you can kind of build out a leg
and then we go to town.
It's like,
hey,
maybe they were pink.
Trx is could be pink.
It could have been.
They could fucking beard color.
We don't know.
No idea.
Yeah,
a couple of feathers and skin
impressions and stuff like that.
We found they may have counter shading
like modern day reptiles and mammals and
all that.
They're darker on top,
lighter on the bottom.
A sharks are great example of that
because that's hard to see.
It breaks up the silhouette.
They had some sort of natural camouflage
to blend in with their surroundings if
they were an herbivore or to Haydn as an
ambush predator.
Their animals.
We can still see analogs today,
but people want to see like,
how do we know that it looked like this?
How do we know that it walked like this?
Well,
we don't know 100 percent,
but we can make inferred guesses because
we have a shit ton of bones to look at.
It is pretty much it.
Is there any possibility whatsoever that
one day we'll find like an intact t-rex
frozen somewhere?
Probably not.
Probably not,
right?
It's too bad because I mean it's,
it's a little different.
Hitting a mammoth that was 30,000
years old,
uh,
like,
like I did in Siberia and a 65 and a
half million year old,
20 foot long,
like walking death machine.
Little little different and there was
no,
there wasn't a whole lot of ice and not
a whole lot of,
uh,
like polar activity during the
Cretaceous period.
That's why there were a whole bunch of
water masses like cutting the United
States in half and most of California
was the Arizona Bay,
that kind of thing.
So finding an intact t-rex,
like frozen,
like holy Shit,
look skin likely we'll probably highly
improbable.
However,
there is a possibility we could find
something like a mummified one,
like maybe the skin,
uh,
the skin had enough iron content in it
and the soil to preserve the soft tissue
of the skin and mineralized the skins
that have a desiccating maybe there was
that one in a billion chance that it
fell in the right spot and got covered
super quick before desiccating the bone
and,
and everything mineralized now when they
go on an expedition.
So say if you're going to Montana and
you look at the Great Western inland sea
and those areas and you're trying to
find some sort of a,
a fossil,
like how do you,
how do you pick where you start digging?
So we,
we do,
we do prospecting.
So we know a worldwide,
there's this tiny layer of iridium,
it's the Alvarez layer where the iridium
was deposited on the planet within the
Shiksa Lube,
uh,
impact or that seven mile asteroid hit.
The Yucatan peninsula blew everything
out of killed.
Everything that you know,
in conjunction with bulk volcanism and
all that.
But first we look at that because we
know that's 65 and a half,
60,
you know,
65 point 6 million years ago.
So we go below that.
We look in places,
we've already found stuff.
We go to a quarries and a previous dig
sites and previous locations,
uh,
that we found fossils and we set up camp
and we just start spreading out and you
walk and look down sometimes for days
and you don't find anything.
Then all of a sudden you find this tiny
little scrap of something.
Pick it up,
you lick it.
If it sticks to your tongue's,
likely a fossil,
and then you start looking for more of
it.
Liquid.
Yeah.
All this sophisticated equipment.
And we look at radio spectrum telescopes
and fucking things that go through the
earth.
And we look at,
you look at.
Because the best way to find fossils is
from shit eroding from the,
from the surface.
It's the best now.
And we find a bone.
We're like,
okay,
sticks to the tongue.
It's fossil.
Then let's look up slope and we find a
bone scatter and then we kind of sweep
away some dirt and like,
oh,
holy shit,
there's a broken bone,
and then we work our way out.
Sometimes it's just what's left of a
single element of an animal that has
eroded and fallen down the cliff,
and other times you could be on the top
of horse mountain sweeping something
away and you run into a brand new,
a frilled dinosaur that you'd never
heard of.
Never.
Yeah.
Never Seen Utah serotypes.
Getty.
I named after a friend of mine,
Mike Getty.
He's the one that discovered it.
Wow.
Yeah.
How many people are out there doing
this?
A lot.
Um,
during,
uh,
during the,
dig season,
which is generally late spring,
uh,
two very,
very early fall.
You've got,
um,
let's see.
The Royal Ontario Museum had a dig out
in Alberta with the Cleveland Museum.
My friend Lee Hall did that.
Uh,
you've got natural history museums going
out to Montana or Utah natural trap
cave.
There's stuff going on in Mexico.
So there's like a big community that
goes out and find stuff.
Um,
I've gone on expeditions here and there.
The crazy thing is we tend to always
come back to the same places.
Very rarely.
It's,
I'm going to just wander Colorado and
find a dinosaur.
I think we need to start doing that
though.
I think we need to start branching out.
We need to get more people interested in
Paleo.
We have to recover the Paleo job market
because it kinda sucks right now.
Paleo has been taken over by food.
Oh,
don't even get me started on that.
Please,
please.
If anyone's on the Paleo Diet,
please stop calling it the Paleo Diet
because it's not.
It would be the anthro diet or call it
the caveman diet.
Regardless.
No.
Well,
people in the Paleolithic people,
they,
they'd grains,
they absolutely hate grains.
They cut out processed shit.
Sure.
But it's the wrong name for it.
Yeah,
it's absolutely the wrong name for it.
And yeah,
just sorry to tangent,
I fucking hate.
No worries.
But when you,
when you say Paleo,
that's where people immediately think
like,
I do crossfit.
So anytime I mentioned Paleo on twitter
immediately,
like five Paleo Diet bots,
like favorite retweet,
like fuck,
Paleo Diet bots.
There's Paleo Diet bots.
Yeah.
That they look for the word Paleo and
automatically like it and retweet it.
What the fuck's the benefit and that.
So everybody that follows those can see
everybody talking about Paleo man.
So the entire paleontology science
communication field on twitter,
whenever we do Paleo,
it blows apart.
That's why a lot of them are using the
English spelling now with an extra a.
how's that?
Where's the ego?
Uh,
after the L.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's P,
a l a e.
Oh,
oh,
that's like tires t why res or
aluminium?
Yeah,
you many was a weird color with you via
trey.
Trey,
Trey.
Trey is when people use,
they use that for fancy places.
When I perform in theaters,
I always have to check to see if it's er
or are even theater theater.
That's weird though.
You guys gave into the Paleo people.
I think that Paleo shits dying.
I think you just ride it out.
Well No,
I think it's been replaced with like
gluten free.
Well,
people will,
Mark Sisson has a better name for it.
He calls it the primal blueprint.
Calls it a like a primal diet.
Okay.
I could see that.
Yeah.
This the Paleolithic connection to know
Greens is just.
It doesn't.
It doesn't jive.
Right,
because when humans started staying
still,
it was because of agriculture because
they found things like wheat and barley
and Rye and simple grasses and all that
they eat and when,
hey,
if we take this with us,
we can plan it.
Yeah.
Or if we stay put,
it seems to be growing.
Exactly.
And is like,
oh well if we mix the water over there
in the dirt over here with these plants,
look the plants plants spread out.
It's.
It's just one of those things.
It's like,
yeah,
we ate grains.
They eat.
Yes,
they eat meat.
It's like,
okay,
I'm a big dude and I drink a lot of
beer,
but you know,
I have a fairly moderate diet.
I don't over do it.
I'm not like snacking on Mcdonald's and
Carl's Jr and eating ice cream all the
time or anything like that.
You do it in moderation and that's what
they did.
They had a different lifestyle.
Maybe they could call it the Paleo,
Paleolithic lifestyle diet or the primal
lifestyle,
because think of the lifestyle.
Not Good luck trying to replicate that.
It's like,
fine,
go out to the Sonora desert and do your
deal out there because if you're really
going to do this diet,
don't use a car and don't use a
computer.
Don't use it.
It's like it has to be your whole life.
Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking.
Just fuck it.
Why not do the Diet?
No,
just go for it.
That seems like a lot of work.
Oh,
hey.
That one guy did it the year of living
biblically.
Biblically.
I didn't see that.
There was a book that came out.
God,
what was that guy's name?
I don't remember.
Uh,
my ex girlfriend had the book on her
shelf and I always wanted to read it and
I never got to,
um,
guy lived according to biblical laws.
Did not wear clothes.
Testament.
Yeah.
So no two cloths.
No two cloths like couldn't eat locusts
and you know,
poor guy,
you know,
because we'll Hakan food is great man.
Yeah.
Well can food.
They do crickets and grasshoppers.
Well,
Hawkin,
it's region down in Mexico.
Molly.
Molly is what?
Hawkin.
Okay.
Here's A.
Well I've had crickets in Mexico.
They,
we,
we stayed at this hotel and they gave us
a bowl of fried crickets like it was in
the hotel when you got there.
Like a little nice little snack and some
fruit.
Yeah,
they're kind of nutty.
Yeah.
It doesn't taste bad at all.
Uh,
I served them for a potluck at the,
uh,
page museum.
Uh,
when I used to work there.
I did a line hit yet people were weirded
out,
but they ate them.
I did lime,
Chili,
crickets and a ring and a reindeer
Chili.
Woo for Christmas potluck.
That sounds good.
Oh,
it was great,
by the way.
Nice elk cooking.
Thank you.
I need to come over and like,
I got elk for you.
You want some?
Fuck Ya,
I got some in the freezer back there.
I'm totally down for elk.
All right.
Because the idea of that is just your.
I love Venison.
I love elk.
I do like game cooking as well.
I don't go hunt it.
Cool.
But it's delicious.
It's the best stuff for you too.
Now there's this whole Paleo thing,
like the Paleo movement like,
but put that aside like paint
paleontology like this,
the word paleontology.
It's kind of misunderstood by a lot of
people and I think that the,
the study of the past of trying to piece
together all these bones and slowly but
surely put together a puzzle of what
life was like before people came around.
It's really important,
isn't it?
I mean,
isn't,
isn't a kind of an overlooked and
underappreciated aspect of science.
Absolutely.
Paleontology the study of ancient life.
That's our deal.
We want to see how we got here.
Like pre humans.
We want to see what life was like going
all the way back to the dawn of time,
the beginning of the earth because it
gives us an idea of how things change on
this planet and how things evolve on it.
The keys to the past are needed in order
to open the doors to the future.
I used to say,
if we know how animals acted,
the Predator,
prey relationships,
different ways that these animals were
evolving and living on the planet and
how the planet change because of that,
because paleontology also deals with
Paleo climate,
Paleo,
botany,
so like old plants,
old climates,
geology,
all of that.
We're looking into the past of this
earth when we're digging in the
ordovician period or a the Cambrian.
We're looking back,
we're opening a time capsule.
$500,
million to half a billion years.
That's Rad.
It's pretty fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's hard to like if you're not.
If you don't do it,
if you're not into like astrophysics,
paleontology,
geology and stuff like that.
It's hard to get a grasp on what
timescale we're talking about.
We are in.
We as humans are an eye blink in the
geological record of the planet.
No.
Four and a half billion years old.
If,
uh,
if you were to stretch that all out,
the entire history of the earth on an 88
foot measurement,
we would be the thickness of a piece of
paper at the very end,
all of human history,
200,000
years of evolution from walking upright
and planting shit and domesticating
animals all the way to iss,
you know,
in orbit,
all of that piece of paper at the end of
an 88 foot long ribbon.
It's crazy to think about how much went
on before us.
That's what's so cool about
paleontology.
It seems like the scale is for our dumb
little brands.
It's,
it's really difficult to,
to reference it.
It's really difficult to like put it
into perspective to think of something
65 million years ago.
You're like,
oh,
well that was a long time ago.
Well,
it was so long ago that people used to
be moles.
Yeah.
And here's some weird mole thing,
right?
Here's another one.
We are actually closer to Toronto source
rex in time than transource rex is to
stegosaurus Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
that'll.
That'll mess with your head.
Somebody told me that we are closer in
time,
that Cleopatra is closer in time to the
iphone than she is to the building of
the pyramids.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck.
And this'll weird.
Yout too.
While the pyramids were being built.
Woolly mammoths still existed on Wrangel
island.
Yeah,
he's right.
There was one place where they were
still alive.
4,000
BC.
What killed them on that one island
either over hunting or a dramatic
climate change.
Uh,
because the glaciers were receding and
they could.
Val competed themselves and if they
didn't have a stable enough population
for genetics,
the old breed yourselves out of
existence.
Is there a possibility there's any
species that we thought were extinct
that are still kicking around like in
the Congo or something like that.
But like Paleo species,
I mean,
anything like along those lines.
Something from 10,000
plus years ago that we thought was
extinct.
Yeah.
The rattle snakes here in San Fernando
Valley,
same rattlesnakes.
Corto the shit.
What's the species name?
They were hanging around the tar pits
with Saber tooth cats and all that
animals alive today we're hanging out
back then.
One of the most common animals,
we found that the pits were bobcats and
mountain lions.
No Shit,
coyotes,
rattlesnakes,
horned lizards,
birds,
uh,
that are still kicking around today.
There are species that survived the Ice
Age because as the glaciers receded and
as the climate changed and as the
Predator prey relationships changed,
it's harder for a saber tooth cat to go
after a horse or a rabbit or anything
like that.
The smaller animals that were able to
outcompete them lived on its natural
selection in a heartbeat.
You evolved,
you know the animals adapt to the
surroundings that leads to evolutionary
patterns which leads to a species either
dying if they are fit too much of a
niche or continuing.
If they're more broad or more focused on
the,
on the environment that they're,
that they're adapting to.
Look at the panda.
If we didn't,
if we didn't,
intercede,
intervene.
Pandas will be gone.
They eat a nutrient,
poor diet,
all they eat is bamboo.
They eat such a nutrient poor diet that
they're young.
When they birth,
they're young has to crawl up and start
nursing.
They do basically nothing.
They're very low rent,
low energy animals.
They would have died out,
but we got involved.
Should we get involved in that or should
we just let them fucking
die up?
Stupid pandas.
Figure it out.
Pitch.
Um,
it isn't that natural selection.
Why do we think we're so cute that we
need to step in and because we've
stepped out of natural selection,
we can now.
We have humans have.
Once we started agriculture,
we removed ourselves once we started
building buildings,
we removed ourselves.
We are the flat earth people who didn't
die off.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
We're living longer and that we're
rapidly approaching idiocracy man in a
way we already there,
right?
With Donald Trump running for president
and all the people that are fucking
cheering behind him A.
Yeah.
Even the Hillary Clinton people.
Some of them are crazy too because
they're just denying all the crazy shit
that she's been involved with.
All,
all four of them.
All five of them,
including Mcmillan are just what the
fuck,
man.
I'm voting Hulu.
I want him to rise up and consume the
world.
Utterly screw it.
Cafe Lulu for America speaking.
Did you ever see,
you know,
there's always been those,
um,
those rumors of or stories of the crack
in the legends of the cracking of
gigantic activists.
Did you ever see those fossils and they
found of enormous suction cups that they
believe might have been a huge octopus
type creature?
No,
I'd never seen that.
Yeah,
man,
I wanted to bring that up to you because
this is something that's absolutely
fascinated me because I know that they
don't have any hard tissue other than
their beaks.
They're all body.
Is there a mollusk yeah.
They're this big fleshy thing,
while the exception of cuddle fish and
ammonites,
the,
you know,
that that had a shell or had an internal
shell.
That's it.
Yeah.
You're absolutely right.
So they have the beak and that's it.
Well,
they've found these huge suction cups,
um,
that were fossilized.
The,
the,
you know,
the image of these suction cups.
See if you can find that.
Jamie.
I know we've talked about it before.
I see these things.
See they,
they think that these are enormous
suction cups from some fucking huge sea
monster.
I thought the caption on the image said
something about it via sore emergency
taken up by seem as you're varying the
bones on a.
What the fuck?
[inaudible].
Well,
yeah.
CEPHALOPODS can do that.
They,
they like,
they like to because they're
intelligent.
Who like to kind of fiddle around.
Whoa.
That crazy.
I'm a a crap.
What's his name?
Tony Martin acknowledges on twitter.
He specializes in trace fossils like
footprints and um,
what would it look like if a dinosaur
threw up and leave,
like that kind of pattern and all that.
His books.
I'll get you a copy of his book.
It's fucking amazing.
He would have a field day with that.
I would like to know his opinion on
that.
I have to ask him.
Yeah,
there's,
it's obviously controversial,
but we do know that there are some
fucking huge squids.
Oh,
they're finding more and more every day.
Yeah.
The colossal squid,
the colossal squid and all that.
I was in
London.
Do you remember?
Just a few decades ago.
That was just a rumor.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Because we would find scars on sperm,
whale carcasses and stuff like that.
It was like,
holy fuck,
what the fuck is that?
And,
but,
and that's the thing,
human nature,
all of us especially,
you know,
you play the telephone game,
like you tell a story and then somebody
else tells that same,
I heard it and blah blah blah.
And then all of a sudden,
you know,
that was the bass you picked up and then
that was the swordfish you've got on the
same trip.
Yeah.
What if,
what if like these,
you know,
ancient mariners,
we're pulling up humboldt squid are like
six feet long and dangerous as hell.
What if that suddenly got larger and
larger,
but maybe they also dredged up a
colossal squid or a giant squid and
things like that as well.
And that birthed the cracking idea.
Well,
because humans like to see patterns and
things.
It's just what we do.
Mammoths,
a mammoth elephant remains that were
found near Greece they thought were the
cyclops.
Oh,
right.
Because it had.
Yeah.
So years that would be on the sides,
would they thought would uh,
or the,
the eye sockets on the sides they
thought were the ears and the nasal
opening for the trunk.
If that was the central I,
because they have big stubby hands,
huge recognizable things like femurs and
Olmos and radiate and fibulas and all
that.
Holy Crap.
It must be this giant,
this 14 foot giant with a single lie.
The cyclops was born.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
So we have an ability to take things and
just run with it.
But it is rad that.
Yeah,
way back when,
like,
like an 85.
I was 10 and yeah,
thinking of like giant squid's eye.
I always like 10,000
leagues under the sea.
That was my favorite ride at Disneyland
before they did the finding nemo thing.
And that's just awesome because yeah,
what if there are sea monsters and then
you start learning about sores and like
Florida and most of sores and atheists
orders and all the things like fuck
there are actually see monsters.
And then today you've got sperm whales,
blue whales,
the largest animal on the planet.
Basically crackings with giant squids.
That's just cool shit man.
It is.
I mean,
and they think they used to be giant
activists to.
Yeah.
The.
The real theory is that at one point in
time there was a 100 foot octopus from
it.
This 100 foot activists probably jacked
a couple of boats.
Maybe that's maybe.
Why would they give a fuck?
We've only.
We've only discovered what,
five percent of the ocean.
That's it.
We know more about the surface of Mars
than we do our own deep sea.
That is so incredible.
It's like we've.
We've mapped a lot of the undersea
service.
The James Cameron has gone
down into challenge or deep and what a
freak.
It's by himself.
Yeah.
But Hey,
he's,
he's got the money.
If I had that kind of money,
it's like the titanic and Avatar and all
that.
Yeah.
I would make my own little bathysphere
and go down to the absolute bottom of
the earth.
But how many fucking people do that?
I mean,
how many billionaire and he's only the
fifth person to ever do that.
I think the first two people didn't
bathysphere one my faith to other people
wanted to know did it after that,
if it goes bad,
it goes so bad.
Very,
very bad.
Like just the amount of pressure you
must be dealing with the bottom of the
fucking ocean.
How many miles deep is he a?
I don't know.
It's something like 38,000
feet or something.
I don't know what.
So what was the neighborhood was six
miles?
Thirty 5,000.
Thirty 5,000
feet.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
Oh my God.
The deepest part of the Mariana trench.
That is so insane that that's why would
he.
What the fuck is he doing?
So I just got back from Toronto.
We're going to be at a cruising altitude
of 36,000
feet.
That's just shy.
Yeah.
So if I was over a plane when he was at.
So if I took a flight over the Pacific
while he was in that water,
he's 65,000
feet below you.
They'll get them down there.
What a freak.
That's how far he's doing to get away
from his wife.
So he's doing,
he's out there looking for monsters
manager.
If he did see something,
there's a,
a really fucking fascinating video of
these guys.
They are in um,
some sort of a,
a,
a vessel,
some sort of a submarine and a whale
comes up right next to it and checks it
out real quick and it's just.
And they start freaking out because you
know,
two persons submersible to go that deep.
The whole thing is those have to be
small and very,
very thick in order to prevent
corrosion.
It's like,
hey,
crush a beer can that.
That's what happens in everything.
Squirts out the amount of pressure at
35,000
feet below the water.
That must be insane.
Yeah,
it's a what?
One atmosphere per.
Here it is.
Check this out.
So these guys,
they're in this thing,
the tooling around having a good time at
holy shit.
Is that a right whale?
What is it?
It's,
I don't know man,
but the bay,
the whale comes closer to the wills are
right there with them and then it
actually,
you could see it like this,
like right up to them.
Fuck,
that's amazing.
That looks like a humpback or like a
right whale or something.
It's got like the barnacles.
It's Beilein of some sort,
but what a giant animal dude.
I've seen them like a whale watching
like off of St Pedro and Channel Islands
and stuff.
That would be.
Yeah,
to be right there.
I've seen them too.
I've seen them off of Malibu around
around this time of year,
right?
Isn't around November.
I think the gray whales are coming.
Yeah.
That's like November,
January,
March,
and then the blue whales or like in the.
I think they're in like spring,
summer.
The ocean is such a trip because we're
right next to it here,
you know,
and like people that live on the coast,
like Santa Monica or houses face the
water.
I mean they're facing an alien world and
that's a whole world out there that's
bigger than the world of dirt and it's
just largely unexplored.
Yeah.
And it's really cool to think about.
And I used to be a diver.
I used to work at the aquarium of the
Pacific way back in the day.
And even that,
just like diving off of blue cavern
catalina or you know,
walking out into the surf at Leo Korea
or something like that or doing la Jolla
or the golf you,
we are not built for that.
No.
And like I don't know how many,
how many of millions of people that
listen to your show have actually not
swam in a pool but like put on gear in
order to survive in an alien environment
because that's what it is,
not just snorkeling,
like you like a scuba,
like full blown scuba gear can get
pretty trippy when you're first learning
how to do it because you are entirely
reliable on this equipment or you will
die.
You might as well be in space really
just going to say that it's the same
thing.
Yeah,
it's an alien world.
Yeah.
And the same thing happens.
You will suffocate or get crushed or
anything like that.
If something goes wrong and you're at
depth or you'll pop freeze and explode
and like you're all the liquid will boil
off your body and out of it in space.
It's just horrible.
Shit.
It's this and we want to go to Mars.
Sorry.
Out of their fucking mind.
These people,
I've been marking them onstage.
Don't want to go to Mars at this.
There's no reason for them.
If,
if Tony Stark,
you know,
Aka Elon Musk can do it,
he's going to do it.
I think you can do it.
I think he can do it.
He's okay.
When we were kids,
how fucking cool was it to see like,
like rockets land vertically in shows
and like Flash Gordon and stuff like
that.
He just did it.
Yeah,
he just did it.
It was a sub portable satellite launch
with a cargo ship to the ISS or putting,
putting a satellite in orbit and then
lands vertically.
A reusable space frame that blows my
mind and even beyond that is when the
curiosity rover landed on Mars.
It flew in,
did parachute aerobraking jen jettison
everything,
and then it was lowered on a fucking
crane from a flying,
like flying sky crane thing and then
touch down and then disconnected and
flew off in nuclear powered
was descended to another planet on a sky
crane that was hovering with rockets.
This is Saifai.
Come to life.
It's fucking Rad.
It's pretty crazy.
I mean,
we live in the future.
we've got fucking all of the world's
information like,
well,
if you have an apple watch on your
wrist,
it's kind of,
it's getting kind of weird,
man.
It's very weird and all that is only
created by people that don't get laid
regularly.
That's the only way it happens.
If you get a lot of sex,
like Dan Bilzerian,
he's not inventing any rockets anytime
soon.
You have to.
You have to have massive dedication to
your task at hand.
And it is until the moment where it does
land,
it's probably really monotonous.
Yeah,
I could see that.
Check and recheck.
And Tesla was celibate.
Uh,
he never.
He was crazy.
He was bad shape.
He destroyed his sexuality.
That was one of the things that he
reported on.
He,
he fell in love with some woman.
Now what does that mean by destroyed his
sexuality?
Whether you castrated himself or who
knows or knows mentally had a breakdown
or something like that.
But yeah,
he,
some of his,
his own reports in his memorias he only
slept four hours a day.
He worked straight through for 20.
You took notes all the time,
almost destroyed his lab with like an
earthquake machine.
Weird Shit like that.
But in the same aspect of him being
completely batshit insane.
The reason why we're in the studio right
now is because of AC power.
That was his deal.
Well,
he had so many different.
Oh yeah.
Just groundbreaking discoveries and
innovations and in his,
his initial idea to broadcast
electricity wireless through the air,
like radio signals that we can all tune
into.
Like Westinghouse was like,
what?
No fuck you.
If you want to build a tower,
how high in New York to do what?
Well,
he wanted to do it for free.
You wanted electricity to be free the
same way.
Radios for.
Yeah.
He was a trippy guy,
it would have been funny enough,
a lot of the flat earth Jack asses
embrace him as like the whole thing and
he wanted free energy and all that.
I'm like,
yeah,
by the way,
all of his illustrations about like
warden cliff tower and you know,
wireless energy and all that took place
on a fucking globe.
It did.
Allegedly allegedly alleged gloves.
I'm sorry.
I would love to play you.
The dinosaurs are not real video to do
it.
God.
See if you can,
would probably can't play it on youtube.
We'll get pulled,
but we could play the audio right?
Play the audit.
We'll put the video up on the screen and
play the audio for you and you could
just fucking.
Your head could turn.
Beet red smokes can come out of your
ears because the thing is about these
videos and this is the issue that I have
with not just videos but also with
blogs.
People.
You're writing things and you're not.
You're not being checked as you're going
along,
so it's just you broadcasting an idea.
It's not a conversation,
and because of that,
you can give off the illusion of
expertise without being checked.
Here it goes.
Dinosaurs never existed by the,
my God,
Eric to bay.
This is the guy,
the guy that does 200 proofs.
The earth is flat.
That everybody has debunked.
Fucking thousand.
No,
no,
no.
She'll start shows or listen to this
guy.
Don't you dare mention Owens name you
asshole.
Wrong.
They pause,
pause,
pause.
Uh,
dinosaurs.
we discovered marine reptiles and the
first dinosaurs about a century before
that.
So that right there,
Eric,
you're fucking wrong lumps.
It's like don't bring your flatter
bullshit into my profession.
Now I'm pissed that we keep going.
Yeah,
keep.
Keep this rolling.
[inaudible].
So that's because we can do things like
look at modern analogs and see how teeth
are fucking made.
We know if it's a Predator or if its
prey.
We know if it's an herbivore or a
carnivore,
we know how teeth are fucking built.
Even back then,
even when they're doing naturalistic
drawings like this,
it's like,
like the,
the,
the Macallan on tooth on my arm.
It is a predator.
It's obviously a met gala or Megla dot.
How do you say it?
It depends on your,
your fastest can be on a different
syllable if it's,
it's both.
It's not like nuclear and new cuellar
no.
No.
Because.
Because it doesn't have to use.
Um,
but it's spelled,
it's spelled the same,
but it's like dimetrodon or dimetrodon.
It's the same thing.
The Gala Donner Megla.
Don.
Oh God.
You're going to keep doing this.
What is it?
Twenty minutes.
Thirty minutes.
Fuck you.
Hmm.
I'm glad I brought a lot of beer.
Okay.
Yeah.
The reason why we didn't know about
things beforehand because we weren't
doing shit like wholesale intellectual
studies of science when people were
building fucking pyramids and stuff like
that.
That's why we have different ages in
throughout anthropological records.
We have the bronze age and Iron Age and
all that because we have to do things
like figure out the land around us and
when we start finding really old bones
like,
hey,
this looks like a really big chicken
bone.
What the fuck?
Or this looks like a huge human with a
single I.
What the fuck?
We start looking at stuff like that
saying,
just wholesale fucking bullshit like
that.
God Damn.
But that's a.
that's what a youtube video,
youtube conspiracy theory video is.
Oh,
I know one person getting to spill.
There's nonsense and they're unchecked.
Yes.
That's why I wanted to play this for
you.
And um,
a response videos can be blocked by the
original person.
They can curate all comments.
They can only allow certain ones
through.
They can moderate everything.
Same with a blog.
Same with all of that.
They control their own criticism.
There's a guy right now that allowed the
Paleo community.
He's going after.
His name's David Peters.
He's a jackass.
I'm who's like doing stupid things like
all reptiles or mammals and all of these
claims should be in this and just all
this crap he wholesale copied and
article from a colleague of mine posted
it,
which is a violation of copyright
because he's attempting to supersede
that work by importing his own ideas to
it.
He will refuse any critical comments to
be posted on his wordpress site.
That's really common.
It's really common with people than the
war of ideas.
In the comments section,
that's where it's being fought.
Yeah.
It's because it's an echo chamber.
It's like people don't look as.
Why do people think the world is flat or
why do people think dinosaurs don't
exist there?
Google boolean search is dinosaurs don't
exist or creationism is true.
Evolution is false.
The earth is flat.
Chem trails exist.
They're creating their own echo chamber
and preaching to their own fucking
choir.
Yeah,
and then they have a message board and
they'd go on that message board.
Massive confirmation bias.
Nobody.
Anybody that doesn't follow that line
gets booted out.
Let's play more of this because it gets,
gets better because they weren't digging
in the fucking earth because they were
all dead.
There could have been.
You didn't know what it was.
That's the thing.
It's like the same thing with mammoths,
cyclops.
We didn't know what the fuck it was.
We didn't know.
It was a massive,
massive elephant species.
We thought it was a giant person.
Yeah.
When the first animals were discovered
in the liberate tarpits,
uh,
before 1913,
they thought it was livestock that got
trapped in there and died.
Then they realized,
holy fuck,
cows don't have nine inch long incisors
that are perfectly evolved to slash open
the throats of things.
And then you started questioning.
So the native Americans and all the
people they were finding possibly
scatters of bone and didn't know what it
was.
Uh,
did the,
uh,
did the northern,
first people start licking bones and
rocks?
No,
we discovered that,
you know,
the science as it figures out going,
hey,
this is poorest material.
If I lik porous material,
it's going to stick to my tongue.
Holy Fuck,
that's a fossil.
This,
this,
this kind of just,
he.
The problem with you,
Eric,
is you are starting from an improper
position.
You are starting on a confirmation bias.
You are stating from the beginning that
dinosaurs don't exist and you were using
peer of Delia and apathy denia the
ability for humans to find patterns in
order to fit your bullshit.
And then only cherry pick what belongs.
That's,
that's what,
that's what he does with fucking flat
earth.
And the problem with this is like I was
saying earlier,
because now the stupid minority has a
voice.
All,
I don't know how many million people
subscribed to his fucking channel.
Every single flat earth dip shit is
going to go 61,000
people.
Okay,
look at that 300,000
views and here's the thing.
Check out the comments.
The comments he,
he carries that calms down are almost
identical.
Look,
34,
86 to 34 slash 94.
Are you kidding me?
Son of a bitch of it.
I remember being forced to have the same
dinosaur toys.
Is everyone met?
Yeah.
That's because it's called consumerism.
Flatter.
If no dinosaur.
What's the point in making these?
Okay.
I see.
Good,
good for you.
Go in there.
Extremely great research.
Loved us very much,
and thank you.
Max Haskins.
Don't breed.
Don't ruin dinosaurs with facts.
Fuck you were my favorite animal.
Here's another problem.
His voice is annoying as.
Fuck.
Oh my God,
let's play more.
Oh,
thanks.
I'm going to open another beer
because we didn't dig.
Okay.
That's because we find the first one and
then we're like,
Holy Shit.
There must be more of these out there.
And then the bone war started between
Ogden and March.
You had the mantle collection with the
first Iguanas,
Don,
that was found and they put it and they
made these really stupid statues and put
them in Crystal Palace in London and uh,
Mary Anning,
one of the first female,
the first female pound paleontologist,
and one of the first people to actually
find fossils.
She discovered the atheists or Mary
anning was the girl from the rhyme.
She sells seashells on the seashore
because that's what she did as a child.
And as she was looking for seashells,
she found a skeleton of an atheist or
buried in the cliff.
Oh yeah.
As a kid,
I think he was 12 slash 13 of holy shit.
I think paleontology,
twitter is going to rip me apart for not
knowing thing,
but come on,
I'm hyped up now.
He's hyped up.
I'm not,
Dude.
That's one beer.
All right.
I've got,
I don't know how many you had before you
got here.
None.
We get excited.
I've got nine more in there.
I'm going to need them.
Uh,
yeah.
It's just so mary anning discovered a
few stores and once you discover
something like that,
you want to go around the world and say,
Hey,
where else is this stuff?
Let's go somewhere that no one has been,
which means North America,
South America,
Tanzania beliefs,
all the things that Captain Jack Ass
just rattled off captain fuck face.
So Tom cat cafes.
God fucking fuck wooded shit given I
don't know.
Just something.
I mean,
yeah,
I stole it.
I stole shit given from a trump thing,
but gibbons shit given like a monkey,
like a given machine.
I think they're technically apes.
Gibbons are apes.
I think givens rates,
they have tails.
No,
aren't believable.
Apes.
Monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes?
No.
Apes and monkeys are prime,
but a monkey is just.
It's not a technical term,
right?
It's not a scientific term.
There was an article that was written
there was explaining that all apes or
monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
See if you can find that.
What was.
We'll go to that afterwards probably
because like one of those beers and.
Okay,
let's,
let's
keep this role and I don't want to.
I want to see how deep we can go with
this.
I can bake character.
I don't know what kind do you like?
Whatever you got,
man.
Have you had a goza?
Yes.
When grady.
Great.
That's because there were two
paleontologists going at it.
Against each other.
Going,
I can find the cooler thing.
No,
I'm going to find more shit than you.
It was called the bone wars.
Ogden versus marsh.
You already talked about this,
right?
Yeah.
What was,
what was underhanded about it?
They would,
uh,
they would,
I'm sabotaging each other's digs.
They would try and steal fossils.
They were assholes,
but because of the competition,
it's like a fight.
When you have one dude,
that two dudes that have been training
all their lives and trying to do the
whole thing,
the more amped up one gets the more
amped up the others gate and it's going
to be a fucking.
Just throw down.
This is what happened to on an
intellectual and fieldwork scale.
You had two guys trying to make a name
for themselves in a burgeoning brand new
field that just wanted to get in and
roll and they had direct competition
with each other,
so it's going to be,
you know,
fuck you.
I'm going to find these bones first.
And it got nasty man.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's like it.
Think of it as Edison versus Tesla's
paleontology.
Right?
Except Tesla wasn't very aggressive.
He sort of let all that shit.
Yeah.
True,
true,
true play.
Keep.
Keep this going.
[inaudible].
Oh,
Cope.
Marsh Ogden.
Yeah.
I said Ogden.
I met Kobe.
My bad.
Fuck you for St.
supposedly.
Bullshit Bull Shit.
Not a false suffocation or fabrication.
Turns out a lot of those dinosaurs.
We're the same species that were
previously discovered.
So.
Oh look,
this sauropod femur looks a lot like
that sort of pod Femur,
but I found this slightly in a different
place,
so I'm going to name it a new species.
Nope.
Turns out those both Brontosaurus or a
pat disorders are triceratops or
stegosaurs,
anything like that,
um,
that,
that is just an outright fucking lie
that he just said,
when things are discovered,
it turns out that they're the same.
It becomes taxonomically what's called a
junior synonym.
So,
uh,
for example,
tyrannosaurus rex had another name for a
really long time.
It's totally mega mega,
no,
regardless,
whatever the first name for it was,
was technically the first discovered
name for it.
But since tyrannosaurus rex became the
more popular,
the more documented,
the more thing that became a junior
synonym or what,
or in that one actually became what we
call no mum obscure them.
There were the obscure name no longer,
no longer talked about,
but that's what happened.
It wasn't an outright fabrication,
it was two dudes finding bones of the
same species or type of animal,
but not naming it the same thing.
So that's,
that's an absolute bullshit.
Eric Dubay outright lie
bullshit.
Bullshit.
A sue in the field museum is,
well,
not 100 percent complete,
98 percent complete,
including formerly unknown elements from
any other trendosaur.
Um,
I believe,
uh,
a commercial paleontology group just
found like in 99 percent or almost all,
100 percent complete dinosaur,
we have found entireties or near
entireties of animals.
So He's right by a very small
technicality of one or two percentage.
Exactly,
exactly.
But what he's implying is completely
misleading.
He's implying that they're finding his
shinbone and drawing an a dinosaur
around.
Exactly.
But no,
like we will find,
we can find 70 percent of trend of
source rocks.
We know what they look like.
So yeah,
we will use three d printing or casting
of all that many.
And Yeah,
I'm happily admitting this because
everyone knows,
or at least everyone should know.
Many dinosaurs in museums are what we
call conglomerates.
It will be a see a triceratops.
The skull will be real,
maybe the front half of the animal,
some ribs,
maybe some tail vertebra or the pelvis
will be from one animal.
We will have to use casts of other
triceratops that we have throughout
paleontology in other museums.
Many of the fossils you see on display
our casts now cast doesn't mean bullshit
created on the spot.
It means very technically,
this is a cast,
it is a replica of an actual existing
bone that was wrapped,
made a mold of and then filled with
resin,
painted to the correct color.
It is the exact match of a bone that
exists.
It is not something we are just making
up.
That is bullshit and I hate that when
they come in and go,
Ooh,
look,
fence link plastic.
Yeah,
it's plants,
snake.
It's all like,
well,
yeah,
you know why fossils are fucking
fragile.
It takes us weeks to get a single bone
out and then it is covered in glue.
It is wrapped in tissue paper.
Sometimes tin foil,
a shit ton of plaster and reinforcement
is wrapped around it.
Then it has to be very carefully slid
down a mountain on a car hood in one
time or airlifted out in another and put
in the back of trucks and then taken all
the way to its museum and incorrect
opening them and then prepared
everything has to get a get left off at
very carefully and we're adding more
glue as we're going because if you
sneeze wrong on some,
uh,
on some,
a mineralized specimens,
it goes away.
It just goes boom.
So you have to work very carefully in a
booth with like an Arab writer.
So you're just,
you're shooting extremely fine particles
just to get the top millimeter of
material off.
This is hard detailed work on things
that are 65 plus million years old that
if we're not careful,
they fall apart.
We are not going to wrap something like
that in fucking steal and put it up on a
mount.
Especially somewhere.
I Dunno,
like Los Angeles where things like
earthquakes happen.
It's statements like that that he makes
are just fucking irritating.
Keep it,
keep it going.
Bullshit.
Bullshit ass a fucking literally
bullshit.
Fuck you,
Eric.
I'm a Paleo Monitor.
You asshole.
I am actually contracted to go out to
fucking building sites and make sure
fossils are protected and dug up
correctly.
In fact,
you know what,
Jack Ass.
I found a whale in downtown La.
Fuck you.
Eric.
Do Bay.
He found a whale.
I found a whale in downtown La.
Oh,
you talked about this last podcast.
You were talking about how they had to
shut down construction.
Exactly.
You know why?
Because building construction finds
fucking dinosaurs and and whales and pre
stork animals.
You Jackass.
Oh fuck.
Fuck you farmers.
So sue was found on a guy's farm.
There have been numerous dinosaurs,
numerous prehistoric animals found on a
guy's farm.
By the way,
there's an entire private area up in
Bakersfield called shark's tooth hill
where they find meg teeth Macallan
Auntie all the fucking time.
And it's in Bakersfield.
It's on private land.
Farmers builders.
Recreational people.
Yeah.
Hey,
guess what?
A couple of people hiking in Red Rock
Canyon up near Palm Dale found a
trackway from an ancient camel rec.
We recreational people.
Yeah.
This happens all the fucking time.
The reason why it's happening more and
more lately is because people know what
they're looking for now.
They understand.
Wow,
there could be shit out here.
Hey,
if we're digging a road,
if we're widening the 99 freeway in
Fresno,
Holy Shit,
we hit a mammoth or holy shit,
we found a whale in downtown La,
like with within blocks of the 1:10
freeway and good Samaritan Hospital.
I won't tell you where I can't,
but yeah,
I just wanted to secretly.
Yeah,
it's just part of the part of the
contracts.
That's the deal because if you find
something,
if you find something there,
you can find more shit.
We found over 400 specimens have sharp
teeth,
whale's a or a rib cage of a whale,
snails,
fossil,
coral,
all of this because downtown La was
underwater 7 million years ago and yeah,
that's.
Oh my God.
That's fucking bullshit.
Oh,
keep going.
Fuck you found all the time.
Bullshit
meaning trained motherfuckers.
Oh,
okay.
So it's perfectly fine to accidentally
find ancient scrolls or silver dinero
die from the Roman period or a never
before known pyramid and South America.
Oh no,
that's cool.
You know why?
Because humans fucking made those,
but it's completely out of the norm for
some kid,
some nine year old kid to be walking
around Montana and find a mummified
Hadrosaur because I don't know why I
made that distinction.
That's a weird comparison.
There's.
Yeah.
It's more plausible defined the Dead Sea
Scrolls in Qumran than it is to find a
mega don tooth bullshit.
Bakersfield.
No,
no,
it doesn't make any sense.
He's,
he's anthropomorphic sizing this and
he's using a very,
an absolutely invalid invalid argument
and a logical fallacy.
He's trying.
He's trying to.
It's absolutely false equivocation.
He's trying to go,
oh well,
you know,
you can't find this stuff because it's
super,
super old,
but you can find this stuff because it's
younger and it's humans and you know,
people live there.
So we'd expect stuff there.
Well guess what,
asshole?
There's 65 million years of difference
between humans deciding to write shit
down and go,
hey,
uh,
there's a day and a night.
That means something's ruling the day in
the night.
God's religion and industry and all
that.
And dinosaurs eating shit.
Sixty $5,
million years.
You were tree shrews and moles.
We didn't.
We weren't building shit.
We weren't writing stuff down.
It's such a false fucking argument.
God,
this guy's a jackass.
No,
it wasn't.
it wasn't because we found a bunch of
shit there.
Like dinosaur national park.
Stop saying for allegedly you son of a
bitch.
Yeah,
because it's a fantastic site.
Oh.
Oh really?
Really?
Hey.
Guess what Eric?
I ran a lab that we had three and a half
million specimens from the ice age that
goes back 90,000
years.
So the labrea tar pits the largest ice
age mammal collection on the fucking
planet.
And this stuff isn't mineralized.
It's actually subsumed with asphalt
keeping the,
uh,
all of the calcium and everything
intact.
These are actual bones.
When we find a saber tooth cat tooth,
it's the fiscal tooth of the animal who,
which is kind of freaky to think about.
But,
but,
but seeing that it's like,
yeah,
we find a lot of shit in places.
The river of death and Alberta when
they're digging the pipeline.
Um,
I dunno.
Mammoth hot springs.
There are things called death traps and
Predator traps in sinkholes and natural
trap caves,
and I don't know,
entire sand dunes falling on things
while they're fighting the dueling
dinosaurs.
It's a produce air tops versus a
velociraptor that was founded in
Mongolia because of fucking sand.
Dune fell on them while they were
tussling around because the hereafter
wanted to eat.
The thing at that.
That's a red specimen,
by the way.
You know what's interesting about this
guy is that he knows so much is that
his,
his knowledge of the history of
paleontology and of researching dinosaur
bones.
He knows so much I call bullshit on
that.
What I'm thinking is that he's reading
from a script that he cobbled together
on fucking wikipedia.
I challenged him to go toe to toe with
somebody in the business I don't know
like me and go,
okay,
start throwing date.
Start throwing specimens.
I will fucking own you,
be.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
he's.
He's obviously,
he knows all these people.
He knows about the bone wars.
He knows who is in charge of all these
different simple google search of
largest dinosaur thing found.
Okay,
I'm going to write these three things
down on this Manila in Manila.
Fucking understand that.
I'm not saying that it's.
It's impressive in that it's conclusive
evidence.
I'm saying it's.
It's impressive that this guy has done
this much research but yet still has
this ridiculous idea and he's using.
He's using all this data that's actually
factual about how many different people
found how many different things and he's
decided that this is proof and allegedly
in front of it.
Yeah.
It's like,
no,
sorry.
Over 6,000
specimens were found there.
Fucking go with it.
[inaudible].
Why do you think it's called the
dinosaur national monument now?
It's key up a actually.
Yep.
It was called the tiniest giants
exhibition.
What the fuck
wrong?
If you find a fall planting efforts,
the plant,
what were the things that they planted?
They.
There's dinosaur bones and they planted.
That's where the dinosaur bones made out
of like residents.
So that is actually an argument with
these jackasses.
It's like,
okay,
so big Paleo.
The big paleontologist people like me be
Paleo,
big Pharma,
big Pharma and big vein and you know all
the podcast Jamie there.
There we go.
We're big podcasts are an industry,
so they say they not in the black man
black helicopter day,
but they as in the detractors state that
paleontologists like me will create a
fossil,
whether it's like a cast or we'll just
make one up and on these expeditions we
go out and we actually bury it and
uncover it and make the news and all
that.
Well,
if that was true,
Eric,
why is it that when we find something,
say in,
I don't know,
2008,
it's not usually written about until say
2012 and that's just assembled a single
note in the Journal of Vertebrate
Paleontology,
which I guarantee you've never read or
it's done as a poster at the Society of
vertebrate,
which I will absolutely guarantee you've
never been to.
And then the fossils still in prep at
that point.
We haven't done all the research on it.
It still undiscovered fossil found.
If we're going out and investing all of
this money in order to make these fakes
and bury them and pay all of these
people to shut them up and huge
excavation is like that,
we would kind of want to recoup that
money as fast as possible and
immediately dump it to the news and get
paid for spokesman ships and all of
that,
but we don't.
We suffer natural history.
Museums are some of the lowest donated
two institutions on the planet.
Art Museums are generally number one.
There are people that get laid off all
the time from museums.
Museums close.
If we were making all this money and
making all this fame,
why are there paleontologists out of a
job?
Why do I know a dozen monitors that
don't have work right now?
Why are there museums that have problem
actually getting a budget to get an
excavation going that they have to use
private donors that they have to use
their board of directors that they have
to go from a county museum to a
foundation,
nonprofit non profit.
This is such a line of fucking bullshit
that.
I mean that.
That pisses me off because his simple
statements are looping in thousands and
tens of thousands of employees and
museums and all of that worldwide.
This would be one of the largest
conspiracies ever other than,
I don't know,
Moon hoax is a NASA earth flat earth and
Shit.
One he does.
Yeah.
That is a good one.
Keep going.
Oh,
let's get them on of a bitch.
What?
The nonprofit business.
Okay.
Eric.
Um,
if,
if that's true,
then why do dinosaurs become passe?
Why does somebody like me who has been
on,
I don't know,
13,
14 different television shows talking
about paleontology,
geology and all that.
I have pitched dinosaur,
like live dig stuff to bbc and all of
that.
I'm consulting on a couple projects
right now.
Unfortunately,
can't name them,
but,
uh,
dinosaurs become passe very,
very quickly because people are like,
oh,
cool.
New dinosaurs found.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
Or Oh,
well,
brontosauruses back.
Yeah,
whatever.
But the mainstream media,
as you said,
is like,
they love
a dinosaur story,
but that's bullshit.
That's absolute bullshit.
When was,
when was the last,
like,
dinosaur document?
Yeah,
there was um,
uh,
what was it called?
Autopsy of a t rex with my friend Tori
and uh,
that,
that.
Okay.
That was a speculative science show.
It was like,
what happens if we found a t rex and cut
it open and do an autopsy.
That was a hit and then paleontology TV
died again two years ago.
I had a knack to our national geographic
documentary about digging up woolly
mammoths in that it aired a night.
There was a little bit of press fucking
done.
The production company that did the,
the,
the thing with nat geo is out of
business now.
Just done.
It's like,
really?
We're,
we're pressured and to get this money
then why aren't we making fucking more?
Why Eric?
Am I a bartender in addition to a
paleontologist in addition to somebody
that's on TV,
if I'm making all this big Pharma or
sorry,
big Paleo fucking money if I'm such a
shill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that why I'm a month behind on my car
payment right now?
Is that why I'm trying to scrape
together rent?
Fuck,
you can aggressive.
I'm very aggressive.
Fuck these guys.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
The bandwagon effect and the crowd
behavior like flat earth bullshit.
Okay.
We're only seven minutes and 53 seconds
into a 29 minute video.
Fuck all.
We don't have to keep going.
I don't want you to get too mad.
I think you Kinda made your point.
Yeah,
you can pull the plug anytime you want,
but now it's like one of those twitter
arguments,
man.
Now I'm getting invested.
No,
that's why I wanted to play fucking
troll me all the time because we follow
each other.
We DM each other and all of a sudden in
my feet it's like I have you on note
because we're both verified.
It pops up and it's just like Joe Rogan
is tweeting but flatter.
I'm like fuck.
And then just go for it.
It's like,
I mean like you know the podcasts and
like flight commentary and UFC stuff and
like with your,
with like triggered coming out and all
that.
That's one thing when you rile up the
cranks man,
you're just like,
you're at the same level.
Actually.
You have.
How many followers do you have?
Like 2 million,
right?
Like on twitter,
the Tdt,
uh,
take that Darwin like 10,
maybe 15,000.
I get the same level of riled from both
of you.
Fuck man.
So we need to fly him out and have him
on the show.
This guy this?
No,
no.
Eric.
No,
no,
no.
Take that Darwin doll.
You know,
he,
he would be rad.
No,
fuck.
Eric Dubé.
If he's ever on the show,
I want to be outside waiting with a
fucking baseball bat.
Oh,
how do you won't be violent with them?
Almost almost
that you want to talk to them what you
have to meet.
I think you could gain a lot from
sitting down with a guy like this and
just sort of picking them apart because
you would realize what he was wrong
about and instead of him being able to
just spout off on a youtube video who
would be checked at every step of the
way whenever he said something
incorrect.
Yes.
But the problem is the only reason why I
would do that,
he will never change his mind.
Well,
he's probably crazy.
Well Duh.
He's absolutely crazy.
But think about it right now,
you have 4 million subscribers that now
know this video exists,
that no eric debase name that know that
paleontologists can get riled up by this
guy.
They're now going to go look,
if any one of your listeners is on the
fence about dinosaurs,
why would you be?
But you could have some.
Those are the people that I would have
to try and convince.
I will never convince him.
I will mock the living shit out of him
until he wants to put himself into a
chipper shredder.
But I will never convince him the and
that's,
that's the thing.
So all you cycle people out there,
we don't do it to try and convince the
big mouth pieces for these movements
were trying to go for the people that
aren't quite sure.
If we embarrass the living fuck out of
these people,
those people will go,
wow,
those guys are idiots.
Why did I even consider that?
The world is flat or the dinosaurs
didn't exist,
or creationism exists.
Or Chem trails are Nibiru fucking rogue
planets and shit like that.
Wait a minute,
don't talk shit about Navero.
Seriously,
don't,
don't even do even.
I just had a little rocky knocky.
We're definitely real and they
definitely came down and they definitely
made people with monkeys.
I've seen clay tablets,
Zacharias,
and they knew they had wisdom.
Yeah.
And Nancy leader with the implant and
said,
oh my God,
really know.
That's the,
that's the queen of Nibiru.
Oh.
So like,
since like 1993 or 1995 or something
like that.
She's claimed that the,
uh,
the Satan's uh,
that,
uh,
know about Nibiru and all that put an
implant in her head and she's the only
one that can talk to them.
Imagine if it was true though.
Imagine you're sitting here mocking army
and this pitch has got an implant in her
head.
She's talking to aliens.
So nearly through the truth.
And she's like,
I've got a message.
Well the thing is,
they've been wrong.
So she is.
She actually made a prediction and was
totally wrong on it.
Maybe.
Maybe they're trolling or.
Well,
why would they tell people what's going
to happen and what's going on?
They don't give a fuck.
We're like little monkeys.
They're like little monkeys with a
lighter,
true,
true.
And that's actually their argument,
their argument.
But if you do the math,
so this,
this rogue planet supposedly has like a,
um,
an orbital period of 3,600
years and it goes out.
It was like 50 a year or something like
50 distances from the earth to the sun.
Um,
yeah,
the orbital velocity of that would be an
excess of 42 point one kilometers a
second,
which is the escape velocity of the
solar system.
Any sort of gravitational pull to a
protuberance that,
uh,
or A.
Sorry,
a problem that would have as it
approached,
I don't know,
Pluto or the uh,
or the Qb,
a belt or anything,
the oort cloud or anything like that.
The slightest bit of gravitation would
launch it out of the solar system on a
who the fuck knows where it's going?
Trajectory.
There's no way a planet the size of
fucking Neptune is cruising in and right
behind the sun on a counter orbit to us.
So according to them,
the earth has stopped rotating.
It has stopped,
orbiting is now just wobbling back and
forth.
And there's going to be a physical pole
shift of the fucking planet.
Oh,
this lady,
this.
Yeah.
This is the Nancy Shit.
There is a planet.
There's something that they found that
it's outside the Kuyper belt right
there.
There is some thing,
some object that they believe is four
times plus larger than the earth.
That is because of a outer orbits of
outer material.
Wiggles just a little bit.
Whether it's a twin son or a dark star
or a neptune size planet or anything
like that.
We don't know.
That is all speculation,
right?
It's like I'm going to jpl next
Wednesday for a tour and talking to
people.
It's that no one knows because no one's
discovered the whole planet x thing.
Everyone's like planning.
An ex was discovered.
No,
it wasn't for planet nine or whatever
the fuck they're calling it now.
It was not discovered.
It was theorized.
There's a huge difference between
hypothesis,
a theory and a discovery.
I hypothesis of,
Hey,
shits wiggling.
That means something may be out there.
A theory is,
hey,
we found something.
We have the facts to back it up.
We are establishing a scientific theory
in between those.
You have the discovery of,
fuck,
we have an image of the planet,
or Hey,
we see it translating something.
It's like right now it's just a theory.
There's no image of it,
but they.
It's just a hypothesis.
Is that even a theory?
They also know that the way that the
Kuyper belt responds and then the
galactic shelf,
the way it ends,
it seems to indicate something of a
large mass.
It's outside their absolutely 30.
They think it's some insane or have it
like a 33,000
year orbit.
I believe it was not a 3,600
years,
so it's really,
really far away and it's really,
really far away and it's not.
It wouldn't be a binary system because
nothing's like figuring through who
knows.
Maybe halley's comet is.
Maybe maybe just maybe,
I don't know.
I'm not an astrophysicist.
Maybe on its 75 year trajectory.
It's flying so fast.
It goes all the way out and flings
around and comes back.
Who knows him?
Well,
jpl and guys like.
I'll ask Fred on what?
What are you doing Wednesday morning?
By the way,
I dunno,
we'll talk about it after the show.
I might be going on with you.
Right on.
I'll be fun.
Yeah.
Private tour of jpl photo.
That'd be exciting.
I know the photographer does sign
shit about so I won't tell them about
fake dinosaurs and shit.
Probably have to be a shell for the flat
earth.
Depends if we go in the clean room or
not.
Or see the see the Mars yard where they
fake the curiosity rover.
I have a friend who doesn't believe in
satellites.
Satellites are low flying planes.
Have you seen that one?
Had He?
Probably.
Either way.
Eddie.
Guess what?
I brought a chemistry chem trails
sticker for you too buddy.
He's still,
he's still,
he hangs onto that Kim Trojan one heart.
So,
uh,
my friend,
I was in Atlanta for a,
for a convention and my friend Tommy
listens to your podcast,
just he's got,
he's got the uh,
the awakened primate tattoo.
I think I sent you a text with a picture
on it.
Okay,
cool.
Like,
um,
he's like a really cool dude.
And he's like,
dude,
did you hear the Eddie Bravo broadcast?
Like,
no,
he's,
he doesn't believe in science,
he doesn't believe in dinosaurs going
fucking chem trail.
What are you talking about?
So we're just defense.
He was quite drunk.
Oh yeah,
I get that.
But,
but you get kind of loose and you know,
your inhibitions get down when he gets
excited about secrets.
Yeah.
He gets excited about secret societies
and,
and these conspiracies and this idea is
very attractive to him that dinosaurs
aren't real and it's all been a scam.
They been lying.
It was bro.
He doesn't believe in science because he
can't do it.
Stuff like that.
Well,
it's just,
it's a,
it's a pattern of thinking that's
attractive to a lot of people.
There's a pattern of thinking that
you're going to uncover some hidden
truths.
Yeah,
because you can be that person.
You can be that famous person.
It's like,
hey everybody,
guess what happened to Geraldo when you
opened Al Capone's vault?
Anybody remember that?
Yeah.
Well that was a chance he took the same
thing or opening,
but that's what you mean.
Not really because Al Capone's vault was
a real vault.
Who knows?
He could have gone in there and then it
could have been something innocuous like
old whiskey or that could have been
something cool like a murder weapon,
who knows,
but but it's along the same lines as you
want to be.
Just like scientists.
We want to find something that's never
been found before and name it after
ourselves or a loved one or really cool
scientists of the past and discover a
new species or discover new planet or
send a fucking rocket to Mars.
We want to do that too,
but it's when you get into the idea of I
want to do that and I want to take them
down.
That's when we have the problem because
you're not using and everybody wants to
say that they're critical thinkers and
all that.
You're not.
You really aren't.
I'm sorry.
Any of Joe's listeners that think of any
of this shit.
You're not doing critical thinking.
You're cherry picking your finding
patterns to fit your model.
You're not looking at countries science.
You're not looking at simple,
simple proof of curvature.
You're not looking at the fact that
museums exist and we have nurse or flat,
but it's Kinda like got like a hump.
I think that's the thing that's a little
bit of a hump to get over.
I would like to make a very public
challenge that any flat Arthur advocate,
if you show me a photo of polaris with a
timestamp and gps coordinates of
Australia,
I'll believe flatter.
What does that mean?
So Polaris is the northern star.
We think about a flat earth.
Okay.
North Pole here flatter if ice wall,
blah blah,
blah.
Got It.
Players would be directly above the
North Pole.
Australia be over here.
Okay.
It would be able to look up and see
Polaris at night all the fucking time.
It was flat.
It was flat because it's a globe because
it's round and the polls are doing this
places up here.
Hey,
guess what?
You can't see through the fucking earth
and see Polaris.
What is this Jamie?
A version of the flat earth that
[inaudible] they think my hus,
they one of the flatter theories.
So this is what they think it is.
Is the metal.
Yeah.
And the,
the go further out.
It's a scoop.
So why would it be like a cigar ashtray?
This is what it is.
Like a cigar ashtray that's floating in
the sky.
That's,
that's based on biblical.
Because you have the quote unquote four
corners of the earth have held aloft by
angels.
And your notion is through space.
Totally logical.
Yeah.
I.
Whereas the penguins above or below.
All around.
But other than the north or the South
Pole,
that's the problem.
So yeah.
Um,
pull up.
Oh,
that's what it looks like.
That.
That's one of them.
That's cool.
That's a good one.
That's a fun one.
Turtles all the way down.
It looks like a chocolate chip.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cool.
So I wonder what.
So.
Okay.
Flat earthers what's on the other side?
How come we can actually.
And they say no flights over the South
Pole.
Bullshit there are there absolutely
flights over the ice continent.
It's like none of the travel times of
aircraft work on a flat earth.
But is it disturbing to you?
Because it's disturbing to me that this
was not an issue three years ago.
You never heard about this three years
ago.
Then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
there's a bunch of people that I get.
If I say,
if I make a tweet about the flat earth
or mock something or put up a video,
I will get hundreds and hundreds of
fucking morons.
I know.
Yeah.
You know,
because you've gotten into with those.
Sometimes I do it and when I see you in
there,
I go,
yeah,
I know it.
I know I'm going to move away for the
text message of like,
Hey,
trip,
check my feet.
I just let it happen to look.
It's up to you.
I don't want to bait you in.
No,
I think I'm going to have to turn off
notifications from you.
I love you man,
but I love you too.
But it's fun to watch you squirm.
You'd get mad.
I get it because it's your business
science.
Ignorance pisses me off.
Science denial irritates me.
What should it should?
Yeah,
because
I'm sorry.
You have no right to be stupid in the
modern age.
You have all of the fucking answers in
the palm of your hand.
What's a co?
Yeah,
that's pretty dope.
But you got there.
Oh,
it's hydro from agents of shield.
Hail Hydra.
You're a grown up kid.
Fuck no,
dude.
I'm Ooh Shit.
Twitter.
Wow.
How many notes?
I'm not even gonna.
Look at my notes.
Look,
they're getting mad right now.
Cobra.
Oh,
come on,
I'm going off the deep end.
I'm Gen x and my license,
my license plates.
Decepticon.
Oh,
alright.
People.
No,
that's fine.
I've posted pictures of the flat.
If people are going to be really fucking
searching for you,
run my plates.
Come to my address and presented him
with the truth.
Come to my address in East Hollywood.
Go ahead and front you with flat earth
reality,
Bro.
You're a shell.
You're a flatter.
It's shale.
A dinosaur shell.
What else?
Big Pharma.
Because vaccines are vaccines are
important.
Big Pharma's Shell.
Uh,
I'm apparently an atheist.
Chill because creation creationism
bullshit.
Um,
what else?
Uh,
uh,
NASA shill for both moon hoaxing and the
bureau.
Um,
yeah,
so I freaked a lot of people out because
when I got my,
uh,
the,
the sticker pack and all that from the
team chem trail,
guys,
I also got patches in a challenge coin.
I,
what's a challenge coin have like a
military challenge coin.
They have it for team chem trail too.
On one side it's the,
it's this logo and the other one is if
you can't beat them Barium,
the element barium that they think is in
chem trails.
Yeah.
Um,
so it's just one of those fun things
because I,
I like mocking the shit out of these
people.
I had an interview one of those guys
that made documentaries about it for.
He was showing wow proof.
He was like,
what in the world?
They're spraying those documentaries.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
uh,
he had proof from this lab that he had
gotten these tests of this water.
Yeah.
And the water,
it was crazy because he was saying,
you know,
that this water shows proof that
aluminum is in the water and they're
spraying aluminum in the sky.
And then what he tested and that has
been debunked.
Midwest has ripped that shit apart on a
on metal bunk.
And a ID bumped it right there.
And there was rain and aluminum exists
in the fucking mentally.
That's what he tested with.
Sludge really said sludge.
Yeah.
So I said to him,
I said,
it says sludge.
He was no,
I gave them water.
I go,
okay.
But the lab says it's sludge.
That means it's an amalgam of.
Yeah.
So aluminum is one of the most common
things that you can find in dirt.
So your dirt tested positive for dirt
and you think that's proof of chem
trails.
And the dude was just like,
just shut down.
I need to watch that one.
I'm thinking trying to find some way out
of it that didn't exist.
I'm like,
I'm trying to be open minded here,
but what you've done here is nonsense.
Yeah.
All of all of them are nonsense.
They find
one tiny little fragment of something
that fits in there,
fucked up worldview and wreck their
entire paradigm around it.
And they make videos and they make
videos and then they monitor the
comments and delete anyone who disagrees
with them or they are enforcing an echo
chamber of bullshit.
Self awareness.
I mean,
yeah,
you're not woke as fuck.
I'm sorry.
I love saying that though.
Well yeah.
No,
because there is a way.
There is a way to be woke as fuck.
How could you please tell me how well,
okay,
look at you dude.
You're fit as your fittest.
Fuck you.
I'm the entire point of your podcast is
you're interviewing people because you
want to know things.
You constantly look for information that
is noble and you make informed decisions
you use,
you use substances to get you into
states.
You are healthy.
You work out.
And the entire fact when you started
coming doing commentary for UFC,
you wanted to know what it was like.
So he started training.
You started working out.
You're embracing the ideal of learning
that is woke as fuck.
You are having massive conversations
with people about every conceivable
topic that's woke,
but I appreciate that,
but I gotta be honest.
I secretly wish that big foot was real.
That's okay.
I secretly wish that Nubira was real.
That's fine.
I will be rooting for this lady with the
chip in our head to be right.
Right.
But that's why I'm,
that's why I'm doing that.
History Channel Show Doomsday we get,
we get questions like,
Hey,
what would happen if an asteroid hits
the planet that like the same size that
killed the dinosaurs.
If it hit,
hit,
hit right now,
last week was the rogue planet episode
one of a planet.
The size of Jews have a neptune rolls
into the solar system on a collision
course of earth.
We're fucked.
Yeah.
Well the first three episodes or we're
fucked asteroid.
We're fucked.
Black Hole.
Very fucked.
A Neptune planet.
Super Fuck.
What do we not fucked by?
What,
what I'm worried about that we don't
have to worry about.
Um,
possibly nuclear warrant depending on
size of the war.
Uh,
if it's like a low yield one between a
couple of nations.
Yeah,
you'll have millions if not billions of
dead people like Indian Pakistan.
Yeah.
Um,
or you know,
everybody in the state of Israel versus
a.
anybody else like Iran that may have
some that,
that kind of thing,
or North Korean,
everybody else.
Um,
depending on the scale.
If it was like super powers,
like old school war games,
fucking Cold War Khrushchev,
Kennedy,
Shit.
Yeah.
We're all screwed and yeah,
you're just,
you're done.
Population falls below 10,000
people.
We can no longer propagate the species.
We are fucked.
But if it's a low yield one,
yeah,
millions,
maybe a billion people will die.
Then you've got the fallout,
then you've got the possibility of
winter and then you have the possibility
of things like radioactive rain fall and
all that.
But there's a possibility we could
survive.
Maybe we can
adapt.
We're pretty good at adapting.
That's the cool thing about humans.
We are tool using primates.
If I was Hillary Clinton,
I'd be looking to bomb people right now
and be like,
this is it.
Low yield.
That's how we do it.
Low yield wore it.
I'm like,
what he's saying,
I'm not,
I'm not a fan of the whole idea of war
or nuclear war or anything like that.
But I understand the,
uh,
the basis behind deterrence.
Well,
it works,
it has worked.
It's worked since up.
And that's the problem with war.
General war works.
Yeah.
It's not ineffective.
It's not like we're going to go to war.
Everybody dies.
No.
Everyone gets diseased and civilization
crumbles.
Know,
make some advances.
Yeah.
Only on completely completely lopsided
wars like genocide in Rwanda or genocide
and Croatia or genocide in Turkey.
Um,
things like that.
those,
those are horribly lopsided or I don't
know,
World War Two,
what he decided to do to.
Wow.
Um,
I won't even say his name a the guy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Say Trump's name or he won't say
Hillary's name,
but he's not yet.
But um,
yeah,
it's like,
I wonder if he'll sue me,
but hey trump,
you're a demagogue.
Read the Ninth Book of Plato's Republic.
Uh,
you are basically illustrated in it and
you are the most unfit person to ever
run for president.
And that includes like dudes like Deez
nuts and all of that.
You're a fucking joke and that he's not
sounded real guy.
Right?
These nuts.
There was some guy that was named
himself deez nuts and like I said,
I'm running for president and all that,
or like the time q guy ran for president
once and I'm hoping that was going to go
on with this election is that trump is,
it's so ridiculous that a guy like him
got so far with as much baggage as he
has as much skeletons in the closet as
much not paying tax is fucking over
small businesses that,
you know,
small contractors that work with them,
the bankruptcy's,
all the craziness,
all the pussy grabbing,
all that,
all that he fucking police so crazy.
So over the top,
off the deep end,
crazy that I wonder if like maybe this
will be the birth of a,
a more,
uh,
a more competent form of government.
Like slowly but surely this battleship,
we'll make some turns because of what
we've seen here.
I think so because interestingly billy
Bush is leaving the today show because
of those comments in the video.
Yet trump is still running for
president.
Well,
billy Bush didn't say anything and he's
getting $10,000,000.
You hear that.
How is that you donated it already said
why?
Because he would be.
Women were hating them already.
What other?
Hey Nick,
listen,
let me.
I'm going to tell you something ladies.
As much as I deplore anything that
Donald Trump said in that video about
pussy grabbing and all that crap.
If I was on the bus with him and it was
just me and Donald and we didn't think
we were being recorded and he started
talking crazy like that.
I had let them go.
Let them go.
I wouldn't check them.
You know I wouldn't check them because
it's not my responsibility.
All right,
and he's talking crazy and when people
are talking crazy,
sometimes I want to hear.
If someone wants to tell me that they've
been abducted by aliens,
they've traveled back through time and
their DNA is being propagated in on
other planets and the reason why is
because they're from a select group of
humans that have existed since the
beginning of time and that their DNA,
even though it looks like everybody
else's is different,
I'll let that guy talk just like I'll
let this pussy grabbing asshole talk.
He's not responsible,
he's a fucking host of a television
show.
He's sitting next to a crazy man who's
talking about grabbing pussies.
You just got to let that guy talk like
for them to,
to fire him for that or be mad at him
for that little heavy handed.
But.
Oh,
he's definitely.
Well he him.
Yes.
Yeah,
but I'm saying that billy Bush guy,
he does what I'm saying.
He didn't do anything,
but the thing is I'm the kind of person
that would check that.
What'd you?
Yeah.
Would you step in and go,
hey man,
don't pussy grab.
Oh,
do okay.
Um,
so hear him talk though.
He's so crazy when you want to keep them
and keep running.
No,
I don't.
Those people need to shut the fuck up.
Well,
I'm a centrist.
I'm a registered independent voter.
I'm an equality list.
It's like I was,
I was gunning for Mccain for awhile and
then until Pailin came along and then he
had his weird little meltdown.
I'm like,
no.
Hey now.
Oh yeah,
don't try.
No.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I can see Russia from my porch.
She didn't actually say that.
Right.
That was an snl thing,
right.
He kind of said she could see Russia.
Wow.
Yeah,
she's kind kinda talking about it.
I always,
I always thought that was like a Tina
Fey,
like snl thing and then they like it ran
into it.
It became that whole,
that whole deal.
She was wonderful.
She was.
She was wonderful because she was like
the first example of this anti
intellectual ism on display,
but other than Bush of course,
but running for president,
running to be the king of the world and
like being one of us being one of us.
Right.
We're all together.
The working class folks.
The blue collar job lunchbox.
Yeah.
And all the cars play tree.
It's got right behind that and all those
gears of war,
medal of honor playing mother fuckers
that have like air fifteens and like,
yeah,
we're going to go take over a,
a,
you know,
a wildlife reserve up in Oregon and all
that.
These are the people that are behind
trump right now.
Yeah.
That,
that Oregon stuff was very confusing.
I had A.
I had a really pay attention to what's
going on with that.
That leads to pay to use federal land to
graze your cattle on.
They didn't want to pay.
Yeah,
it's our land.
It's the United States government.
The entire United States people own that
land and the Blm is the recognized
authority in order to monitor that land
and the Blm is one of the lowest paid
divisions,
so they need those licenses and fines
and all that in order to function and in
order to do things like build fencing
and allow places like all the national
parks and Blm land and all that in order
for us to enjoy that.
Yeah,
exactly.
It was a very confusing argument that
the argument they should be able to
graze for free was very strange.
It's like,
well,
why should you not be able to pay your
way?
Because they're the weird
constitutionalist sovereign citizen Shit
because you're looking at the federal
lands.
They are without a doubt,
a national resource,
right?
Yes,
absolutely.
It's a resource and in those resources
you're going to have food for animals
and this is what these animals are
grazing on.
Well,
that also gets in the way of all these
other wild animals that we protect like
buffalo,
like the American Bison,
they need those and here's what's really
crazy about it.
They're killing bison in in large
numbers and they're calling them in
yellowstone and one of the reasons why
is because the they will escape,
they will leave the parks borders and go
into these areas where traditionally
cattle have grazed and they're so big
and so robust that they sorta devastate
these areas and then it effects the
cattle market.
A paleontology came across that too.
Did you?
We think that a couple,
a couple research researchers have
considered that the expanse of the
Antique Bison,
Bison and Tequilas and the longhorn
bison pies and Lana fronds.
When they came across the bering sea and
got into North America with the
recession of glaciers,
they out competed mammoths.
They out competed a lot of natural
grazing herbivores because they eat
faster,
they're larger,
they breed quicker.
They can basically terraform and area
of.
They can eat saplings from trees and
grass.
They can drink mud and get hydrated.
These are amazing,
well evolved creatures and well adapted
to that environment that got into the
perfect environment to just go and
that's why we didn't have any native
horses.
We didn't have any native elephants
anymore and all that.
The Bison out competed.
So what you're saying?
Absolutely.
The bison rolls into cattle grazing
land.
It's gonna fucking take over and thing
is you can actually make Bison Buffalo,
buffalo in a.
In cows and buffaloes.
Yeah.
It's amazing to me that they didn't
embrace the bison as more of a domestic
animal in that sense because it's so
much more robust than a cow.
I mean,
obviously cows are great and everything
like that,
but you can't tell me that bison meat
doesn't taste great.
No,
it's way leaner.
It's awesome.
That's fantastic.
It's higher in protein.
It's,
you know,
and especially
if they're grazing on grazing on grass,
not grain fed is higher in Omega threes
and sixes.
It's better for you.
It's,
but we fucked that all up in the 18
hundreds with like over hunting a bison
and near extinction and market hunting.
That's what they did.
And sometimes they would leave giant
piles of them just for their tongues.
They would just take their tongues and
killed them for that and then hides and
a bunch of different things.
And Yeah,
they did a number on them in the 18
hundreds.
Yeah,
it's a shot in the dances with wolves.
That old costner flick where they come
over the hill and obviously the white
men was here because there's just
skinned buffalo carcasses like as far as
the eye can see,
because they were just going for the
Peltz Peltz.
We're selling that season.
It's dark man.
It's dark.
When you consider that what they did to
all the different animals on the planet,
it's pretty fucking incredible.
What is the impact that human beings had
in such a short period of time of the
impact we're having on the environment
now in such a short period of time.
It's fucking crazy.
It's like we need to become more
responsible with figuring out what the
fuck we are doing.
Are you aware of the American Serengeti
Project?
No.
They're trying to buy up giant chunks of
private land in the Montana,
Wyoming area and they're trying to build
a park even larger than yellowstone and
what they're trying to do is sort of a
habit.
This national park where you know
there's a,
like a robust supply of Bison,
wolves,
coyotes,
all the,
all these different things and they're
trying to.
They're spending a lot of money and
they're also running block management on
it,
which means means they're going to open
it up to hunters as well and they're
trying to take these areas of private
land,
buy him up and then slowly converted
into a gigantic public park that they
think,
you know,
as far as the animals that have
survived,
that will in some way mimic the
original,
what they call American Serengeti.
That would be fucking cool.
Pretty interesting.
There's a guy named American prairie
preserve.
Oh,
neat.
Reserve.
The idea of it,
the only question I would have for them
is,
are there other species that have now
adapted for the area that they're doing
that they will impact with this?
Saying that is what happens.
The rattlesnakes are.
They're a smaller cats like bobcat's,
things like that.
If you were taking burrowing owls,
if you're taking a bunch of things that
are no longer in the area or very sparse
in the area and then you are condensing
them into a spot and then kind of making
a Serengeti theme park,
I don't mean to offend them,
but that's just kinda the gist I'm
getting.
If you fill it full of things that
aren't there now,
you're going to be displacing things
that are there now.
That's true.
I think what they're trying to do is
they're looking at what happened in
Africa,
like in Africa instead of large scale
agriculture.
The way we've embraced that in the
United States for,
for most people,
they think about food.
You know,
they go to the store,
they go to the grocery store,
they go to the vegetable aisle,
they get their food.
But very few people actually go to visit
these enormous swaths of land that had
been converted to large scale
agriculture.
Right?
And we think of large scale agriculture,
large scale,
um,
you know,
like ag gag laws refer to factory
farming and things along those lines.
We don't think of factory farming in
terms of vegetables,
but even that itself has had a
devastating effect on,
uh,
on different parts of this country where
the,
it's just the soil has been completely
depleted of minerals and needs to be
constantly replenished with minerals
every day.
But when you look at what they did in
Africa,
they sort of decided to take these parks
and convert them into these enormous
wildlife preserves.
And so these animals exist more or less
in a very similar state to the way
they've done thousands of years ago.
Okavango Delta Reserve and all that.
Yeah,
that,
that's red.
But are they importing animals into it?
You'll see,
I don't know what they're going to do as
far as bringing in animals,
but what they've done in terms of what
they've done and yellowstone,
when they brought in wolves,
I'll say,
although this region was once known for
its abundance of wildlife,
current wildlife populations are greatly
diminished.
American prairie reserve works to build
wildlife populations in three strategic
ways,
collaborating with state and federal
agencies who oversee all wildlife
management decisions on their population
targets for at risk species such as the
swift Fox partnering with ranching
operations around the preserves edges to
increase tolerance for wildlife.
That's a weird word.
Tolerance for wildlife,
reducing the amount of kills and the
regions habitat fragmentation
like tolerance for wildlife.
It's like.
I'm sorry if your ranching nearer of
thing like that,
you should be tolerant
of wildlife.
Well the problem is if feel like it
interferes on their,
on their private land,
that's where it gets weird,
right?
If there's not a fucking fence a lot,
they can keep a buffalo out.
Oh Hell No.
If it wants to go,
it's going through.
So this idea that you're going to put up
a fence and then somehow know that lush
green grass is going to be saved from
Buffalo.
Not really.
They're just gonna fucking headbutts.
That fence
says bison restoration.
They've reintroduced bice in 2005 after
120 year absence.
Hm,
interesting.
Yeah.
So they are.
They're doing importing animals.
So how are the 120 year Absence Bison
over the last 11 years impacting the
cougar,
the Swift Fox,
the pronghorn black footed ferrets and
grassland birds,
all of that.
That's like,
I want to know more before I would sign
off on something like that.
It's like how much?
How many bison did you introduce?
Um,
what is there a propagation?
What is their current gestation rate?
Um,
what is their current,
a birth to death ratio.
How are they impacting a place that they
haven't been for $120?
One hundred and 20 years for a lot of
animal species is a very short amount of
time.
For others it's just the right amount of
time to start really adapting to an
environment and establishing an entirely
new Predator to prey relationship with
things.
They're,
all of a sudden you put in this
monstrous fucking three ton beast
that could screw a lot of things up.
Yeah,
it could.
I mean,
they require a lot of food,
a lot of resources,
and we've seen what happens when they've
done things like this.
Well,
particularly with wolves in yellowstone,
it's been really fascinating to see what
the impact it's had on animals and how
the animals have sort of shifted where
they live and behave and it's uh,
it's,
it's so cool.
But it also,
it's also like,
man,
what a cautionary tale.
We're kind of like playing,
playing creator and a lot of ways by
introducing these things.
We have a big debate going on that right
now in paleontology,
the whole cloning deal,
cloning wooly mammoths and all that.
Where do you stand on that?
Um,
I kind of stand on more of an empirical,
uh,
area that as of now we have not
discovered viable enough material in
order to clone something.
The technology is not there.
I've,
uh,
I've talked to a while.
I was in Siberia and a couple of years
ago I talked to you some of the leading
geneticists from South Korea,
like in Sung Lang and all those guys,
and they're saying like maybe 50 years
because the way the cloning a has to
happen,
we have to find viable DNA,
a complete,
like a complete individual genome plant
that into for woolly mammoths
specifically plant that into the nearest
living relative,
which is the Asian elephant.
That means we have to harvest an egg
from a female Asian elephant,
which is difficult to do.
We would have to harvest many eggs
because Dolly the sheep had like 870
some odd tries before 12 stuck and one
was born.
Trying to do that with elephants,
they go into must every like for three
days out of a year or something like
that.
I don't know the specifics,
but that's a huge monumental tasks to do
by itself.
I've seen woolly mammoth carcasses.
I've looked at them under biological
microscopes.
I've taken tissue to have put into
scanning electron microscopes.
We've looked for viable DNA,
have not found any fat fragments.
Sure,
but not in the entire thing in the
genome.
This animal went extinct.
This animal went extinct possibly with
human interaction.
We're not quite sure yet,
but definitely through an inability to
adapt to a changing climate.
This is the perfect example.
If humans were not involved of natural
selection,
this animal could not live in the
environment anymore.
That being said,
should we establish the Pleistocene Park
in Siberia and clone woolly mammoths?
I don't think so.
I think this would be better used
and not being a genetics expert or
geneticists at all.
I think it would be better used for
actual human interactive deaths,
Dodos Moa,
Tasmanian Tigers,
passenger pigeons,
things we have specimens of now that
would be easier to do.
Like they're working on patches,
passenger pigeons right now with the.
I think it's the three bard pigeon,
maybe just a bard pigeon genetics,
twitter and correct me on that.
Um,
but what is important about bringing
back that pigeon?
I mean obviously there's a principal
because their response,
we're responsible human beings are for
their minds I think.
I think that's,
that's it.
It's maybe it's,
maybe it's the idea of,
wow,
we fucked up,
right,
but hasn't 90 percent of everything
that's ever been alive dead.
Oh yeah.
Like 90,
95 percent of every single species that
has ever been on the planet.
Four and a half billion years is
extinct.
Right?
So where do we stop?
Like,
why,
why bringing back the Dodo bird and the
Tasmanian Tiger and not the woolly
mammoth because the dinosaurs,
the early,
you know,
early placental mammals,
Tiktaalik,
all of that going way back in time and
things like the wooly mammoth through
the saber tooth cat or the steppe
mammoth or the,
uh,
you know,
the s stegall,
mastodon or mastodons,
those went extinct.
All,
whether it was like a cosmic impact,
huge volcanic eruptions,
climate change,
the oxygen suddenly dropping in the
atmosphere or in the ocean.
All of that happened through natural
resources.
We have now overstep those bounds and we
are responsible for the extinction of
the golden frog,
the passenger on poor golden fog.
I miss it.
They're cute.
I don't even know they existed.
My life would not be impacted one way or
another.
What it probably not but,
but,
but we killed.
Do you think,
what do you think that the world around
them,
the natural world has adapted to them
being extinct and we should just leave
well enough alone that that could be the
same argument as I was making against
the Bison.
Absolutely right.
Think about all the money that would
have to be spent to bring back the Dodo
bird.
I personally say,
fuck the Dodo bird.
I don't miss him.
Plenty of cool birds.
They can go fuck themselves.
I mean we have things like the African
African shoe bills and stuff like that.
Man.
Shoe bills are the shit.
They're like one of my all time favorite
animals.
Cassowaries when men cassowaries are
fucking dinosaur to gas.
Warri cassowaries are the spell a ca?
Sso w a r y.
is that like a shoe bill?
Uh,
no.
It's scarier.
Ooze carrier than issue.
Basically.
This really cool looking semi flightless
bird that is an ostrich bro.
Close.
No,
we want the one.
We want the one with the head crest.
Yep.
Oh,
now Google Castle warrior attack.
See?
But that's not as cool as issue bill.
They're and they're pretty and
everything like that,
but bills have the coolest bill.
Shoe bills have a goddamn hatching on
their face.
These have those like rapper clause.
They what they do when they attack,
they kick up and try and [inaudible] oh,
Yep.
There we go.
Oh,
this guy's coming at it with a board.
Yeah.
It's like you,
you will get owned by category and
they're big man.
How big are they?
Uh,
you know,
they're,
they're decent sized pushing six feet.
Nine,
26.
What happened?
Sixteen year old Philip Mclean.
Did he get jacked?
Yep.
He got killed.
Oh,
third tallest,
second,
heaviest bird.
Whoa.
Look,
have a look at those.
Feeding clause was fucking things.
Yes.
Christ,
they've run 49 miles an hour.
They're four point nine feet tall.
Oh,
look at those clauses are horrific,
man.
Yeah,
well they're,
they're trippy dude there.
And look.
Hey,
that's like a t rex foot that is a
theropod foot.
And get to get them in a heel hook.
That's the key.
The key is you got to get a hand on one
of the,
the bottom of one of the feet,
like the ankle,
like right where it meets the foot.
You get a hand on one and then you stay
on the outside and then you want a
butterfly hook the other side and just
snap that leg.
I don't think they would even know how
to defend.
They probably shitty defensive.
Probably try to peck at you.
You know that's not going to help.
What a weird animal for the shoe builds
cooler shit.
Sorry.
Okay.
They look,
they do look cooler for the head and
they can like die this too.
They have those fucking evil rasterize
and they again,
they can totally just like NAC.
You with that?
Would that delegate elegant?
Like look at that fucker.
My favorite videos online is a shoe
bill,
which is this fucking dinosaur bird eats
this snakehead fish,
which is this fish that can figure out
how to get out of the water and walk to
the next pond.
So this prehistoric fucking creepy ass
bird kills is prehistoric,
creepy ass fish that can walk on land.
Like literally it's a walking,
transitionary fossil.
Yeah,
it is fucking walking on land.
It's,
it's a crazy video man.
Is this.
It may be.
They're so creepy.
Look into they just so heartless.
We it back in the,
uh,
back during the age of mammals,
a post dinosaur.
Uh,
we had things called terror birds.
Yes.
We were talking about those yesterday at
like eight,
10 feet tall.
Giant flightless birds with a huge
fucking battle axes for phases.
Yeah.
It's like,
so here we go.
It's a little smaller one.
That's a small tear bird.
And they were predatory monsters just
running around Jack and things.
They're not flightless though,
are they?
I don't know if they are.
I don't like it,
right?
Don't believe so.
It is kind of amazing when you,
when you find out how many different
animals existed in North America alone.
Just 10,000
years ago.
Camels started here.
Camels.
All dogs.
Yeah.
I'm reading a coyote by Dan Flores.
I wanted to read that.
It's fucking great.
It's crazy.
It's what a crazy animal.
A coyote on this by the.
Well,
it's nuts.
He's coming on the podcast.
I think he's going to be here in January
whenever he's in town.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
he's,
uh,
if you want to listen to him too.
He's on the mediator podcast with Steve
Rinella maybe six,
eight months ago.
They did a podcast together and I've
listened to it three or four times.
It's amazing.
Right on horses.
Horses started here and went extinct
here and made it all across the world of
the rest of the world.
And then were brought here by Spanish
settlers.
That's what they were brought back.
Yeah.
And then now they're everywhere.
There's wild horses.
Thousands of them.
Tens of thousands.
All throughout the southwest.
Yeah.
It's the really cool things like that.
And when the isthmus of Panama,
when Panama of rose up and connected the
two continents together,
you had the,
just this awesome transition of life
like llamas and birds and a big cats and
that back and forth just to show why the
pronghorn antelope is so fast.
There's so much faster than anything
that could catch it today because they
lived and they evolved in a time where
there was like Cheetah,
like cats morass and Onyx,
the American Cina the bad ass and beyond
that.
So everybody's like,
oh,
we had cheetahs and we had to cut lines
that were bigger than African lion.
There a trucks,
half a ton of angry.
Eight,
9,000
pounds.
Is this Kerry diving?
Everybody's like,
oh,
well,
you know,
saber tooth cat.
It's not tiger.
It's kept.
By the way,
I'm a.
I just wrote from working at the tar
pits for five years.
A seller with a,
uh,
we know,
we don't know,
but we can guess that they were because
they had short tails.
They're ambush predators because of the
environments.
We find them in a likely they had a
longer coat.
It was counter shaded maybe with some
sort of borrowing or reticulated pattern
in order to blend in.
Think like a really big scary bobcat.
A okay.
Somebody tried to tell me that a bobcat
and a mountain lion with the same thing,
but yeah,
I was like,
what?
No,
I'm talking about are all the same.
Cool.
Mcconkell Laura.
Yeah,
Pumas,
mountain lions.
The same thing.
This guy was trying to say that a bobcat
was same thing because I was saying that
I saw a bobcat and it's cubs recently
and I thought it was a mountain lion
because I saw it for us second,
like a bar,
like not even a second,
like a half a second.
And my friend saw it before me.
I turned to see it and it was a mama
with her cubs and my brain when they
said a cat,
my brain was like,
oh,
they must be in a mountain lion.
So like in my mind the half of a second
I saw it.
I had seen a mountain lion,
but it was actually a bobcat and this
guy was like,
well they're the same thing.
I was like,
no,
the fuck.
They are like not even close.
It's not like a wolf and a coyote.
A wolf can fuck a coyote.
Yeah.
And they can make babies.
Kyle could fuck a dog.
We're all.
Everything is a wolf.
All those things.
All wild canids.
They're all interchangeable because they
are only a few of the canus genus that
cannot do that,
I think.
Which ones?
Um,
uh,
one of,
the uh,
actually knows.
Yeah,
there's a jackal.
I think the black back,
maybe the black back.
Jackal.
Um,
God,
I used to know this because I would
throw this creationists all the time
because they're like,
oh,
you know,
it's the same kind.
It's like,
well these can't fuck these,
the,
there you go.
Um,
uh,
but like African spotted dogs are
totally different genus,
a absolutely 100 percent totally
different genus.
They're part of the Kennedy family,
but they cannot breed with anything
else.
So can they breed and make a hybrid like
a lagger or no,
not even.
No,
not even close.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
It's like,
but you know,
the biological definition of species
does kind of break down because it
depends whether it's a environmental
species or if it's a general articles.
Fokker yeah.
What a face on Halan Rad.
Look those big ears.
Perfect for just like tracking stuff.
Now was the only asshole tried to take
an African wild dog like that in turn
into a pet.
No idea muscle.
You right.
Maybe African hunting dogs,
you know,
I dunno.
I'm wild looking dog man.
I looked so wild there.
So the coloration of the.
It's like so dynamic.
Yeah.
But if you,
if you look at that pattern,
you've got lights and darks and look at
the material behind it,
look at the grasses and they blend in.
Yeah.
They're,
they're literally like walking asap.
Cammo,
right?
Yeah.
Like Jamie,
Jamie to go back up to that one with the
teeth opened.
The picture you just showed.
Look at that.
Like that pattern.
I mean that is a perfect Predator
pattern.
They sort of blend into the background,
especially from a distance if they're
not moving because most animals they
pick up outlines and then they pick up
movement.
Yeah.
Then if the outline stops moving,
it disappears.
Yeah.
Especially with a cryptic coloration
like that.
Yeah.
It was incredible.
That natural selection has led them to
have those kinds of coats.
Well,
there's a here here in southern
California.
We have two different kinds of snakes,
um,
or actually it's the same species,
but they have totally different color
patterns.
The California king snake,
the white and black ones that you see,
they're either abandoned or striped.
The abandoned ones,
the ones with the horizontal across
their bodies,
they tend to stay curled up underneath
bushes in the desert.
So as they're white and black.
Yeah,
there we go.
So the abandoned ones like that,
they stay,
they stay curled under,
uh,
under trees because as the sunlight is
coming through,
it's creating bands across the road.
So they blend in.
The striped ones move more so the
shadows are longer.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really tricky.
Fuck No.
How the fuck does that happen without
Jesus?
You explain me.
This is proof positive.
Just like the banana,
the atheist nightmare.
That banana.
Oh,
rate,
comforts,
banana.
Oh yeah.
This is proof positive as well that the
Lord works in mysterious ways.
Ray.
I'm sorry you ever did that.
I'm happy he did it and I'm happy that
the other dude was right next to them
smiling like it made sense.
Kirk Cameron.
Kirk Cameron just fighting off the urge
to soccer cock with every ounce of his
body just fighting off the gay,
like it's a horde of angry zombies
coming over a hill.
That picture of Ken Ham,
Cameron and fucking comfort.
It's like,
that's like three heads of Sarah bis the
dog from hell.
Like three heads of the hydro right
there and just don't see hell.
And now I just see foolish people.
Well,
yeah,
I just see it,
but I'm the czar foolish people.
I see hell for science.
I see a problem for science in science
education and everything going forward
because these are the people that are
building fucking full size arcs in the
middle of God governs tendency when that
crack another one then beer.
So I'm happy doing that.
Yeah,
that was,
that was great.
What,
when was this called?
This was a from the Sierra Nevada.
It's a Goza.
It's a beer.
Yes.
Come with beverages.
No,
I'm totally into beer now because I'm
solely into what,
what got you into the beer for the uh,
I've always been into beer.
I've always wanted to be doing like home
brewing stuff.
But because the Paleo market kind of
dropped out,
my friend owns a bar and he's like,
Hey,
my bartenders leaving,
I've been drinking here for like five
years.
I was part time security because they
still had a guard card and all that.
Um,
he said,
hey,
my weekend bartenders going,
you know,
a lot about beer,
the whole menu here.
Do you want the weekend shifts?
Since you're not working Paleo people
want to come visit you and stalk you and
give you a hard time about the flat
earth with bars.
And so it's the faculty in East
Hollywood.
It's seven zero,
seven North Heliotropism,
heliotropism,
melrose.
You shill.
They're coming at Chanel.
Ring it with flat earth knowledge.
Bring it.
Yeah.
It's like you want to roll in.
I'm having my birthday party there next
Friday.
The 28th,
8:00
PM.
No such thing as gravity.
It is a magnetic electromagnetism.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Um,
our stickers magnetic.
Oh,
good point.
There you go.
Is Glass magnetic is plastic?
I mean,
come on man.
That's bullshit.
Well,
it's kind of funny.
Oh,
let's go like Ray Comfort,
like Ray Comfort.
And Kirk Cameron and poor bastard,
if he could just find a man who loved
him.
Yeah.
Just come.
Just come free like you see it coming
out of him.
Did that bullshit creationists Christmas
movie that he had last year?
Um,
uh,
you mean awesome movie like San God's
not dead.
Is that the one?
No,
no,
no.
I'm thinking about saving Christmas.
Oh,
saving Christmas.
It's like the war on Christmas and Kirk
Cameron's going to save it this
December.
Oh yeah.
I think it actually took over.
Battlefield Earth is one of the worst
movies on CMDB or rotten tomatoes.
Well,
I would see how it'd be in that
category,
but did you ever see the one that he did
about those Christian novels about the
left behind series?
Yes.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
I bought,
I bought it on vhs.
It's one of the last vhs tapes that I
bought.
That's Rad.
Yeah,
I own it.
I own,
there's two of them.
I never even got through the first one.
I'm like 45 minutes in the first one.
My eyes are sweating,
shaking or I remember when those came
out,
like in bookstores that like the actual
book series I was walking by and like
probably buying like a Neil Gaiman book
or something like that,
like comics or some like cool,
like Scifi fantasy stuff.
When I saw that,
I'm like,
what?
The rapture is come.
There's only a few people left on the
planet,
man.
Fuck that.
Just put it right back on the shelf and
kept walking through.
The rapture comes in.
There's only a few people left.
So that means that God comes and takes
away all the Christians that would leave
a lot of fucking people like this idea
that it would only be a few people left.
It's kind of.
Yeah,
but the thing is,
it's like,
why is he going to take the Christians
if you know Jews?
I'm genetically Jewish.
I have the,
the Ashkenazi k one and haplotype uh,
Mike [inaudible].
My mom,
um,
aren't we supposed to be the chosen
people?
Allegedly allegedly 100 million,
140 slash thousand dollars,
something like that.
You have a.
Once America came along,
God changed teams right?
He got super down with the even ray
comfort.
He decided as an Australian,
he got to get in,
get in tight with American Christians.
Can wait.
Is Re Australian or this?
CanNot.
Both of them are Ken and re like if you
have a had him talk,
but here it's like really?
Oh No,
I'm sorry.
I'm thinking of.
I'm going to give you other jackass.
I'm thinking of the other jackass.
Kent Hovind,
the one that went into jail for tax
evasion.
Yeah.
He's Dr.
Dr.
No,
not happening.
Dude.
Does he have anything to do with that?
Creationist museum will.
Who has something to do with the
creative?
That's Ken Ham.
That's captain ham sandwiches.
Wonderful man.
Yeah.
With some wonderful ideas.
That creations museum and the Ark.
A love the arc and I hate to say it.
Okay.
Hey,
atheist twitter followers.
Don't roll me for this.
Ken Ham is fucking smart because of the
way he does his advertising because of
the way he does his look at that bigger
than imagination.
That's like,
okay,
sure.
He may be completely,
you know,
chewing his own skin off at this point.
Losing money,
but think of what he did.
He did a huge debate with Bill Nye and
got this going because all of the money
that people spend on dvds and all that
went to this too.
If you can get an annual pass for only
175 bucks,
that's way cheaper than Disneyland.
You can go see it all year round.
You just keep going back and see that
same stupid wooden boat all the time.
Wow.
Goes.
I liked the zip points.
I'll kind of zip.
I'm on a zip line,
zip and right off the top of the Noah's
Ark,
right into the manger where the baby
Jesus was born way up at the bottom of
his plan.
He can didn't know what have ziplines.
Is that,
is that how he got all the animals off
the Ark?
Yes.
Well,
that's also had no raised funds.
Oh,
right,
right.
All that would.
So where were the dinosaurs on the Ark?
They were,
but fucking dinosaurs are gay.
A lot of people don't know that.
That's why they all died off.
There was none.
No one was there to breathe.
They were all just doing each other.
There was a far side by Gary Larson,
one of those little comics a long,
long time ago.
It was like the real demise of the
dinosaurs.
They're all smoking.
There was another one that's A.
Noah has a like a 105 howitzer mounted
on the nose of the arch and firing it at
the dinosaur arc.
It's like what really happened?
Stuff like that.
It's like people make fun of this shit
all the time.
Teach the controversy is a t shirt deal
and it shows.
I have the shirt.
It's Rad.
You've got a triceratops with an ox
harness on it and a guy with a plow
behind it.
Then you also have the devil bearing a
dinosaur.
Bones is teach the controversy.
They have a flat earth one,
a chem trail,
one and Illuminati one.
Their fucking Rad.
I wonder how much longer that kind of
thinking that kind of a ray comfort
thinking is going to be around just we
have youtube.
Man.
You think so?
I think it's just going to get louder.
It's just going to get louder.
I think that.
I think not,
I think this is all this,
this ability to self publish and this
kind of stuff is all cute and
everything,
but I think it's a,
it's a step on this inevitable path.
I think we're on a path of complete
enlightenment.
I really do,
and I think it's fucking Rad.
I think it's going to bypass all of our
biological limitations.
I think technological innovations going
to bypass the biological limitations
that we're going to live in,
some sort of an augmented reality,
augmented by technology.
I think we're going to accept that and I
think we're going to.
We're going to dive into that and then
once that happens,
I think slowly but surely just like the
difference between what we know today
versus what we knew or people new 2000
years ago is pretty goddamn radical.
But when you think about 2000 years in
terms of the earth,
it's nothing,
right?
Yeah.
It's no,
it's,
it's a blink of an eye.
Yeah.
It's,
it's the nanosecond reaction of a neuron
firing.
I mean,
even just 300 years ago,
just think of the timeframe between,
uh,
the Wright brothers first powered flight
and landing on the moon and then from
landing on the moon to the space shuttle
to the ISS.
Now we have vertical landing rockets,
nuke powered rovers with lasers doing
science on a different planet.
And we have two probes rapidly exiting
the solar system.
The voyager probes,
they're fucking gone.
Go from the invention of radio to the
Internet today.
I mean,
it's a blink of an eye.
Yeah.
Tiny,
tiny,
tiny amount of time and massive progress
has been made.
And you still have these assholes that
right.
Make these videos about dinosaurs not
being real or write blogs about the
earth being flat,
but at the end of the day,
I just feel like that is more dismissed
than ever before.
Less less likely to be adopted.
And I think it's dying.
I think it's the seemed like the last
blips of ignorance where people are
fighting against this is this the death
knell is this people like Bob,
like going against Neil degrasse Tyson.
He's a silly man.
You know what I mean?
He's just a rapper,
right?
He doesn't really have to have any,
any real data,
but I think that that's what we're
seeing with all this stuff.
I think we're seeing sort of the last
gasps of of ignorance,
but he has a bunch of people that
immediately do that and then a bunch of
people go,
Whoa,
look.
In contemporary times it seems like it's
seems like it's a big deal,
but now thinking overall to be a
conspiracist it's cool to be a
conspiracy sheep.
It's like hip and Rad to think the earth
is flat and all that shit not really
have be a real fucking moron.
To think the earth is flat 2016 to when
you really do against them every fucking
morons.
No,
there are absolutely fucking 100
percent.
I don't think it's going to last.
I hope not.
I hope not because it's drowning witches
once it's fucking exhausting for you
because you keep biting into it.
The thing is,
again,
I want to mock them so the people,
the people listening and the people
watching and all that go,
wow,
that guy's a jackass.
It's like,
it's like the earth is not flat.
I got suckered into it,
but also I have to admit it.
I kinda like out trolling the trolls
man.
Yeah.
When,
when they come in and you just like set
the perfect thing and they come back
with something stupid and just fucking
grabbed by the back of the net and go
and they're done.
It's just like you like setting them up
with facts.
Yeah.
I like setting them up and watching them
just trip over.
You enjoy that so much because they are
dumb enough to do it to other people.
They deserve to have it done to them.
Right.
I'm doing addictive narcissistic
assholes too.
Even when they're doing it to other
people,
they're doing it to themselves.
I like to give them.
I like to troll them with facts and give
them just enough rope to hang themselves
and completely embarrassed themselves
and they,
they do it all the time and then they
get all flustered and they blocked me.
I did that to the Institute of Creation
Research.
They got so pissed off.
They blocked me on twitter and that was
a badge of fucking honor with the tooth
for creation research.
What kind of research do they do?
ICR Dot org is the same thing as like
answers in genesis and all that shit.
It's like it's a think tank of creation
of scientists that are the earth is
6,000
years old are they are the new book of
beginnings,
a practical guide to understanding
genesis.
Oh yeah.
Shit.
It looks like the little fucking
dinosaur on it and look into this.
Look at this first article.
Magic words can't explain strange
fossil.
Once upon a time,
only a single Italian fossil across
crushed specimen at paleontologist had
to reconstruct represented the extinct
reptiles.
The girl was his name.
Direness worth Panna Saurus.
Now a team of American scientists
describe a new Japan,
a sore,
a specimen from New Mexico instead of
fingers.
It had a massive claw on each hand and
it's curling tail was claude tipped.
These features have evolutionist
scratching their heads over where it
came from and why it looks more like a
particular living memo than a reptile.
Well,
guess what?
Because mammals existed during the time
of dinosaurs done tauntaun and you have
things like synapsids and things like
therapsids that are mammals that are
reptile or mammal transitions and you
have all of these things that exist that
they say don't.
It looks like a bear and a sheep and a
slaw had a gang bang.
Right?
No,
it's totally some like Brian Thomas.
Really?
He has an Ms.
He's got a master in science from.
Where did he get that?
Probably from the,
uh,
from ICR.
I think you can get one online.
Yeah.
No you can.
I want to get one just so I have to be
called doctor.
Like he was doing a lot of the,
I know a lot of,
uh,
homeopathy,
people that go and get the homeopathy
certification and like,
and then go,
hey look,
I'm certified to.
I'm allowed to talk to it and we're now
on the equal footing.
And then they just like own the,
the shaken water sugarpill people.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Not not talking about like actual like
aroma therapy things or things that
actually like a like single
concentrations of Arnica that actually
can be used as an antiinflammatory.
I'm talking like the sugar pill,
Bella,
Donna,
things that you take because your ci is
messed up and you can in your ankles,
so you get like pig bladder and Bella,
Donna together and you're just taking
like 40 grams of soluble glucose in a
sugar pill.
Makes you feel better and briefly.
Yeah,
because you're like,
whoa.
That was amazing medicine.
Yeah.
Incredible power because I feel the
spiritual energy because all the,
you know,
your adp going on in your body.
It's just like,
hey look,
we've got food.
I do yoga,
so I'm around these people all the time.
I'm around a lot of these Topanga Canyon
hippies.
Wow.
That believe in all this cookie shit.
It's hilarious.
Talk to them.
They just have these fucking bizarre
ideas.
I've had a couple people come into the
bar lately and again I'm saying it's
like,
hey,
my birthday soon.
They're like,
oh,
when's your birthday?
I'm like,
it's the 27th,
and they're like,
oh,
you're a Scorpio.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
I've.
I've been called a Scorpio before.
Whatever.
It's like I'm dark and brooding and
narcissistic.
Well,
yeah,
a little.
I'm very vengeful,
you know?
I'm very emotional and things like that.
All those things seem to be true.
Yeah,
but all those things seem to be human
qualities.
No,
no,
no.
Just for Scorpios,
just for Scorpions.
No,
no.
Pisces.
Pisces,
or like different.
Very balanced.
NASA,
your Zodiac sign is wrong according to
science,
but it was never based on science
anyway.
Yes.
Well,
what is it based on and how fuck has it
been around so long?
That's what's really incredible about
astronomy,
but rather because of the ability for
the human brain to look at patterns.
We see constellations.
It's like you.
It's like the same thing with
constellation.
Same thing as clowns.
Oh look,
there's a dinosaur.
Oh wait,
no.
Not string into an alligator,
and now it kind of looks like my mom.
I'm feeling weird because of that.
You know,
that kind of good friend of mine who I
really respect telling me that astrology
is real.
Then he conducts an astrologer before he
does anything that's important and he
won't do things with the astrologer,
tells him that could be dangerous or
could be problems coming in the future.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I was talking to him about it and he
was like,
well,
the astrologer,
they told me about my past.
They told me they were right about my
parents.
I go,
don't you know about your parents?
Don't you know,
like,
why would you be excited if someone told
you some shit you already knew how to
tell this motherfucker to tell you some
shit you don't know,
you know?
Tell him to tell you a lottery ticket.
Tell them to tell you what's going to
happen next Tuesday.
Then believe him.
Otherwise what they're probably doing.
Use asking you leading questions.
You're answering them in a way that
leads you to believe that they had the
information.
Yes.
It says con man stuff.
It's cold reading.
It's mediums.
It's hold all of these.
There's techniques,
training and micro expressions of
magicians are fucking excellent.
Adam.
Oh hell yeah,
man.
I mean I.
I'm a really good friend of mine is a
misty Lee.
She's the only female medium at the
magic castle and she's Rad and we were
just talking one day and she's like,
Oh yeah,
I can speak with the dead.
I can find anything out.
Just by doing that kind of is like
magicians.
There's entire books written on this and
I've watched.
I've watched penn and teller do it.
I've watched Uri Geller do it the whole
deal and it's if you work in enough and
magicians have the type of mentality and
patience and discipline to do this over
and over and over again.
Shuffling cards a thousand times a day
until it's just rote memorization.
They can do that with cold reading.
They can do that with predictions.
They can do that with math tables,
deep boone bending,
all that stuff.
They know to do all that.
That's easy.
You get a spoon with a little bit
gallium and it melts when,
as soon as you touch it with your inner
guru or gallium gallium.
It's a metal that actually melts,
uh,
with,
your simple body heat really,
and you make spoons out of it.
That's the common thing.
I'm not spoiling any magic trick,
so it looks like a spoon.
It's made out of metal,
like regular metal,
but it's actually made out of gallium
and just sort of rub it.
You Rub it and it melts and the thing
falls apart yet.
Check it up.
Disappearing spoons.
Okay,
so this guy's got a spoon,
doesn't that it looks like a normal to
do it yourself.
Kit and gallium metal metal available.
Sounds like a spoon.
So that's a thing of hot water dot.
Oh Jesus.
The spoon dissolved in the water because
it's hot enough.
It's,
it's a,
it's a low yield temperature.
This is not an acid.
It's water melting.
Point of gallium is only 86 degrees
Fahrenheit.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
What's,
what's your outer skin?
Body temperature.
Oh,
96.
So that's incredible.
So you can take a hot water,
so your fingers,
you could easily been that spoon and
just rubbing it or not even that hot
that it would hurt you.
Or if that's an opaque mug.
If I'm a gallium spoon,
I do that.
You can't look through the mug.
The spoon disappears and it melts away.
Oh,
that's.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a very simple one.
And you know,
bending spoons like that.
Yeah.
So they just rub it and the gallium just
sort of bends or there's a wave shit.
There's a way to pinch it between your
fingers and start rubbing it and you're
actually working it back and forth just
a little bit like bending a key when you
like it.
We've all done it.
We've all rubbed a keen.
We've watched it start to bend because
as you are heating it up,
it is expanding its Oh,
is that?
Yeah,
there's the mold.
Check it out.
What's happening here?
They're making,
they're messing with gallium.
You can make a mold of it and then you
put it in your freezer eight hours
later.
Oh Wow.
This is so bizarre.
Yeah,
it's tough.
Just breaks in your face.
It's neat stuff,
man.
What did.
Whereas gallium from it's part of the
periodic table,
it's a existing element until they find
it in dirt and extract it.
You can mine it.
I've lived 49 years.
I've never heard of gallium to this
moment.
You're welcome.
Just thank you very much.
You should feel good about.
That's the entire point of your show.
You learn shit.
That's what do.
That's why I've always been a fan.
Well,
thank you.
Yeah.
I mean,
listen,
I'm a fan of the show too because it
allows me to have these conversations
with people.
Like I'm saying that I'm not being
facetious like as a,
as a person who's in the show,
like I'm a fan of being able to be able
to talk all these people.
Like you learned about gallium.
It's cool.
Metal bending spoons.
There's so many different tricks that
magicians use that psychics and all
they're really sleazy people have been
using to steal from people like these
goddamn mediums on television that you
see that.
What was that Long Island medium?
Did you ever see that one yet?
No.
What was the Big Guy?
The dude that had the TV show?
Oh yeah.
Our started like Robert Richard Byrd
something.
What was that fucking guys name?
He had the same name as somebody else
that's famous,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
and he would use plants and wireless
mikes and audio amplifiers and cold
reading to read his audience shit.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
He had that Scifi show on Scifi,
like beyond with rural,
whatever is his fucking
name.
Thankfully we have forgotten he has
fallen into obscurity,
but that piece of shit was famous for a
long time and people would talk about
them all the time.
Yeah.
He started with specials and then he got
his own damn show like that done.
What's his name?
Jamie James Van Praagh?
No,
no.
There was another one.
It was fucking people right now are
screaming it on twitter.
Probably this guy.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those fuck heads out
there,
but again,
just like the flat earth people and all
this other nonsense,
I think they're going to exist less than
less and less in the future.
You know?
I think that what we're seeing right now
in terms of confirmation bias,
I think that's all going to be
eradicated because I think what we're
dealing with now is very limited mediums
of draw,
of writing things down,
typing things,
making videos about things.
All of these things are incredibly
limited in comparison to,
well,
what's coming up,
you know,
I've been a,
I'm a follower of Ray Kurzweil for
awhile.
I'm trying to pay attention to what he
predicts in what he's,
what he's thinking is going to be coming
down the pipe and 20,
45 and you look at guys like him and all
of these futurists that are predicting
all these emergent technologies are
going to completely change and revamp
the way we communicate going into the
singularity.
Yeah,
I think we're on the.
We're on the verge of a storm,
uh,
in innovation storm that's going to
render the landscape almost
unrecognizable.
I think we're just a decade or two away
from just massive,
massive shifts.
It brings me back to,
you know,
I'm not a,
I don't believe that the Mayans were
correct at December 21st 2012 was the
end of the world,
but it is fascinating when you see like
the Kali Yugas and all the different,
the different ancient civilizations that
predicted cycles and cycles of humanity
and it kind of seems like there's
something to that,
like maybe almost like you can kind of
predict a sort of a time period where
people accumulate a bunch of
information,
makes,
make life safer for each other,
but then get soft,
soft and sort of sloppy because life got
safe and when you get lazy and then,
you know,
uh,
all sorts of weird behavior.
Like that's what we always thought about
Rome.
Right?
And we will start the decadence and the,
and we know the vomitorium Amelia's,
do you know what it really is?
That's the,
the,
well,
at least I've always been the learn that
it's the kind of like the closed in Bach
and all festival where you go and you,
it's a sauna and you eat a bunch and you
do the whole thing.
I'm gonna help you out here.
Vomitorium vomitorium is,
is actually the,
the,
the passage way between a large arena
and the stands.
So the way people leave when they leave,
that's the vomitorium,
but the name of it led people to infer
that these that's vomitorium.
So lead people to infer that,
oh,
that was a place that we'd go to throw
up the.
No,
it's totally owned on that.
Right on.
Thank you.
But it's,
it's one that I thought too.
And then,
you know,
you always connect that to ancient Rome.
And I went to the Vatican.
I went to Rome this past summer and I
went to the colosseum and go there.
Fucking dope,
dude.
It's the Vatican is the dopest Shit I've
ever seen in my life.
It's so insanely massive and spectacular
and the construction is just so mind
blowing.
The fact that they did all this without
power tools,
they did all over the course of hundreds
of years.
They built these amazing,
massive strokes
teachers.
I did the same thing in Israel a couple
of years ago,
like,
like going to Jerusalem and seeing,
holy shit,
this is like Herod built this wow and
going to Masada and all that.
It was trippy as fuck,
dude can only imagine.
It's like and walking through the
different quarter,
uh,
you know,
the different quarters in Jerusalem and
everything and almost walking up the
wrong stairs and the Muslim quarter to
get to the,
a dome on the rock.
I didn't know where I was.
This big dudes like,
you're not Muslim.
You're not going there.
I'm like,
oh wow.
So you've go the wrong way and you can't
go if you're a Muslim,
you,
unless you're a Muslim less,
you're a Muslim.
Yeah.
Because the,
the,
the Dome on the rock where the mosque
and everything is,
is for Muslims only.
They only open it think one day a year
very briefly for people to come,
like take a picture of the outside.
Occasionally film crews can go in there,
but that's about it.
And it's like,
unless you were devout Muslim,
you can't go in there.
And because it's a very holy site for
them and,
but going there like going and seeing a,
like a,
uh,
the stations of the cross and the Church
of the Holy Sepulchre and all that,
it was trippy.
I'm not an,
I'm not religious,
I'm not an atheist or anything like
that.
I'm just,
I'm a scientist.
I'm an apathy as died.
It's a absolutely.
The religious aspect and spiritual
aspect to me is completely irrelevant if
there's a,
you cannot prove nor deny that there is
any kind of outside force or you know,
three o being and all of that.
I don't,
I honestly don't give a shit.
Uh,
if I die and all of a sudden it's like,
oops,
sorry.
Okay.
No,
I admit I was wrong.
Send me to hell.
Sorry.
I don't care what you think that God
would be like,
hey man,
you didn't know.
But I've always been honest about that
because people are like,
you're an atheist.
I'm like,
actually,
no,
I'm not sorry.
Yeah.
An atheist has to have a belief that
there's no god.
You have to.
You have to believe there's,
there's,
you don't.
You don't know if there's no god because
you've never experienced death.
It's you don't know if there's no
afterlife because you've never
experienced it.
The the,
the is no evidence that exists.
The definitely.
I know a lot of atheists that use the
definition that you have.
Agnosticism and atheism.
Agnosticism is the knowledge.
Atheism is the empirical data,
so an atheist knows there is no god and
disbeliefs all God.
The only difference between a atheist
and a Christian is that the atheist
disbelieves one more than the Christian
because if you think about it,
because in disbelief scientologists,
they disbelieve the moonies.
They displayed the Unitarians,
all of that.
So an agnostic is lacking knowledge.
You don't.
You don't really know.
It's like,
okay,
well I've seen some things.
I haven't seen other things.
That kind of deal.
I removed myself from that and the
hardcore atheist community has tried to
grasp apathy ism as,
Oh,
it's practical atheism so you don't
bother.
You don't care,
and it's like,
no,
we don't care because it's a waste of
fucking time.
Yeah.
I had a argument with a guy on twitter
once was a twitter,
one of those things where he was,
um,
he was saying,
why don't you just come out as an
atheist like,
well,
why do you care?
Why?
Why do you care?
Why do you want me to say there's No
God?
Why would you want me to say that?
First of all,
I don't know.
And I've said I don't know.
And you don't know either bitch.
So why are you telling me that I should
say that.
I know,
right?
But you don't know this is,
this is crazy talk,
but it's one of those goddamn things
where people want you to be on their
team.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's like,
oh,
hey,
cool.
We have a celebrity endorsement.
That's exactly what it is.
It's exactly what it is.
Joe Rogan said he was an atheist.
So all the atheists go on the part of
the atheist society.
We get together,
right?
That's happened with the skeptics.
There used to be these skeptics society
and then they got weird and then they
got all social justice Warrior II,
and then they started accusing each
other of raping each other because they
were having sex while they were drunk
and it all got madness.
It's a lot of is falling apart in a
bunch of people won't go to their events
anymore because they were accused of
impropriety and,
and then you have new ones like in,
uh,
across the pond.
You've got like qed con and stuff like
that.
They're actually doing it like the old
school.
It's like a bunch of people are meeting
up and talking about things and they
have panels and they have like zero
tolerance,
a law,
uh,
you know,
zero tolerance rules for the convention,
stuff like that.
And that's the zero tolerance for what,
for like sexual harassment or anything
like no means,
no consent laws and guidelines and all
that.
And it's really cool.
Um,
they need that at conferences.
Isn't that just common human nature?
They needed somebody,
they needed some.
Well it is and a majority of people
should know that.
But then we have,
you know,
rape,
advocating,
fuckwits that run for president.
Um,
so he's in the pussy grabbing but still
rape advocation.
He's absolutely advocating the abuse and
rape the locker room talk or shifts in
the locker room.
I played fucking hockey.
I played football.
I've never been in a locker room,
first of all.
No he has not.
And it's like,
yeah,
it's absolutely just put.
So like there's a big thing every year
I'm a,
I'm a guest at a dragon con.
It's a pop culture con in Atlanta.
Right.
And because it's all fan run and they
have different programming tracks
that I go talk on the science track,
you know,
talk about beer and cooking or
dinosaurs,
or two years ago I ripped apart Jurassic
world,
stuff like that.
And like Jurassic world,
fuck no,
but dude,
the people that you loved made it to the
end and lived.
That's the best part about the movie,
that Chris Guy and a beautiful girl.
It was really,
really bad monster.
It was really good because the little
kids didn't die either.
Those kids made it.
Are their parents back together?
The dinosaurs were running after the
kids and the kids got away from the
dinosaurs and survive.
That's a good movie.
They hid behind the jeep.
Good job.
Their dinosaur didn't get him even
though he smelled them.
You can't put a smile on that or you can
not hold character in good movie.
First of all,
what's that guy's name?
Chris Pratt.
Pratt is a beautiful man.
I'm happy he lived and the girl,
they wound up being boyfriend and
girlfriend at the end of the movie.
So it's a good movie.
Who saw that comment?
Who saw that beautiful man in the
beautiful girl getting together at the
end?
Especially through the movie when they
shot it at the beginning,
but no,
they joked about that.
They went on a date before.
So of course,
you know the stressful situ.
We look at,
look at speed and plus he said,
ah,
I didn't watch that movie.
Didn't have any dinosaurs in it,
but the data just don't exist.
They're only in movies.
I'm super intelligent.
Dinosaur crushes that little thing that
they're in,
but they managed to slip out the bottom
and the dinosaur doesn't say it and then
they run off.
It's boiler spoiler.
These little kids,
a tiny little stubby,
shitty human legs can outright.
A fucking dinosaur.
The size of a building size of a five
story building.
There's things screaming and Taran trees
a heart and he's on a fucking death run
to get at these little kids for some
reason.
Yeah.
With all the other dinosaurs and shit.
So you gotta eat those gigantic head.
You just want to eat these little tiny
people that are barely a snack.
Right?
Right.
It's like you chasing after an aunt like
that.
That fucking man.
I did it.
That one right there.
That motherfucker.
Yeah.
That was a good movie.
A good movie.
It was good at the end to where all the
daniels came in and pick people up.
Uh,
yeah.
And Jimmy Buffet with the cameo running.
Jimmy Buffett was in that.
Yeah.
So they have Jimmy Buffett's
Margaritaville stand at the thing when
the,
uh,
when the dimorphic dons and the horrible
dimorphic Don's in the really shitty
trended ons come out.
Wait a minute that we've seen the same
movie.
Yeah.
They can't lift people up.
I'm sorry.
It's my job.
I can't imagine a movie like that.
Plausible deniability where tools.
What's the terra dactyl?
The Tabernacle is a species of Toronto
on.
Okay.
So those Taran and Don's,
there were,
there was wrongly campy pick people up.
No,
they weigh less than most people.
How much they weigh maybe somewhere
around the small ones,
like 75 pounds.
And they don't have the foot strength.
They have the foot strength in order to
hold their body up.
The thrust to weight ratio,
man,
they can't reach down.
They don't have the grip to grab an
eagle that can grab a sandwich.
No,
no,
no.
Different sort build.
Totally different
build.
They got.
Sorry.
They got fucked by evolution.
Did they have feathers?
Those fuckers?
Possibly.
Um,
okay.
Now I have to say a couple things in
your ESCO world.
We're Kinda cool.
Like the most pat's face.
No,
I liked it more than covers girlfriend's
face.
Okay.
Now bryce,
Dallas,
Dallas breakdown was Kinda hot.
She's even going to fall behind a high.
What do you have high standards you
fuck?
Well,
no,
she's who are,
you know she's even hotter in the marsh
and I have to say,
oh,
the marsh.
Absolutely beautiful machine.
The marsh.
He's the commander of the areas for
mission expression.
They,
they.
They went crazy.
Science fiction.
They have a chicken control.
Let's just,
let's just do this.
Just go off the deep end.
Believable.
That's not cool.
Social Joel's to US interests over
household.
A little bit of it at that.
Okay.
About that term.
Social Justice Warrior.
Yeah.
It's wonderful term.
It can also be used for the opposite.
The people that are going for no
political correctness,
that people that are going on that they
want social justice on their side.
They are also social justice warriors.
They're looking for,
but that's not going to stick.
That's how white people honkies doesn't
hurt.
Have you called someone to mock social
justice warriors?
A social justice warrior two because
you're trying to.
You're trying to eliminate all political
rectus.
You're social justice war they have.
Okay.
Whatever,
Dude.
No,
I,
I haven't had them off that you have and
it has pissed them off.
Piss them off.
Oh No.
They started like the argument and Piss
people off by calling him a fucking a
nanny.
You stupid ninny no.
Oh God.
There was one guy I called a chump and
he was like,
you wouldn't say that to my face.
I'm A.
Yeah,
I would jump is a what was,
what was his twitter handle?
I don't want to come.
You need to call them out on twitter
here.
No,
well I don't remember it anyway,
but he chose a.
it's really kind of innocuous,
right?
Yeah.
Call me a chomp.
I'd be like,
all right man.
I'll let you have that.
We'll just end this right?
Oh yeah,
you fucking pussy.
Oh Hey.
You're a chump.
Alright,
we're good.
We'll just leave it alone.
Shop if you're happy with chop all this
lady.
It's like you're not calling like a
mentally bereft muppet or you know,
some kind of just like,
we'll see.
You like to get verbose with fucking
self.
You like to go deep with your education.
I have,
I have.
I understand.
Decent vocabulary.
You're fucking paleontologists.
I get it.
Yeah.
Use what you got.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
See some dudes just chomp is where they
draw the line that he got mad and then
he tried to go.
It's like,
oh no.
I was laughing at.
I know you work,
dude.
You're moving the goalpost.
Come on,
and some people do get really upset.
It just really innocuous words.
Yeah.
Choose have words.
They choose where they decide,
but none of them ever stick on white
people.
That's the amazing thing.
There's never been a single racial slur
that stuck on white people.
Yeah.
Their house.
One name,
one name one.
What can you call us?
A company.
It can't fucking even hate saying them,
but there's been a Hemi with it slur
against Jewish people.
No white people.
Not Jews.
Tattoos and specific,
but that's still quite sort of a white
Anglo Saxon.
Protestants.
WASPS.
That doesn't hurt anybody.
The bitches laugh while they're using
their credit card,
but it didn't.
Ha.
That was.
That was a slur back in the day back
before people could read and realize how
stupid it was.
Spain.
Shit,
dude,
that doesn't hurt nobody.
You can't.
You can't come up with on.
Well One's one that is sticking right
now and I'm Kinda glad it does.
Is White privilege.
That doesn't stick.
Fuck yeah,
that's that stick and harsh.
And I told her the wrong crowd,
trevor.
I'm hanging out with smart fucking
people,
man,
because if white privilege hurt them,
if you say that the EU,
how?
No,
no,
no.
Those are not people I hang out with.
Oh fuck no,
no.
I've been watching the reaction of
people.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
White privilege is totally fucking
thing.
It's absolutely a thing.
It is documented is proven.
There's institutional racism is a
hundred percent fucking fact.
Well,
what white privilege is,
is sort of the lack of racism against
white people and in highlights racism
against other people.
So what white privilege really is,
is how everybody should sort of be
treated.
Everybody should be treated like they're
not a criminal waiting to be discovered
exactly right,
but that's not really a privilege for
white people.
What it does is it highlights that
there's racism against people who aren't
white,
so like to say that white people are
somehow our fault because there's a
racist biased against people who are
brown or black or Asian or or what have
you.
It really kind of shifts the blame and a
kind of a weird way in my opinion.
I mean I think it's a real thing for
sure,
but I think really what we should
concentrate on instead of concentrating
on getting white people to Kowtow and,
and to bow down to the fact that they
have privilege to just eliminate racism
from the world,
which I think is an entirely a possible
thing in our lifetime.
It's totally possible.
But the problem with that is we have to
come to terms with being privileged.
We have to come to terms with we the
terms.
Yeah.
We have to.
You know,
people have to understand that yes,
because you are white,
you are privileged because you are
white.
You will not get pulled over as much.
You will not get shot as much.
We have to come to terms with that and
in what way?
Because we're the ones doing the
institutional racism.
We not.
We were not doing.
Not when someone is someone.
Yes,
but who are these people that are doing
that?
Right?
Police officers,
yes.
Right.
Sure.
Police officers,
politicians.
We have an issue with police officers
first of all because I don't think.
I think there's almost no one who is
qualified to be a police officer.
I think it's an insanely difficult job
that we just assume people can handle
and I think it's a chaotic,
ridiculous amount of pressure that these
people have to endure on a daily basis.
They're pulling people over.
They have no idea they're going to be
shot.
They see death every day.
You see people getting shot and
accidents and murders and domestic
violence and chaos and I don't think
people are psychologically able to
handle that.
I think we think of it as a job.
Every few,
absolutely.
Very few.
We think of it as a job the same way we
think of camera repair and you know
someone who builds cars.
It is not.
It's not a job.
It's an incredibly difficult
psychological endeavor to try to take on
the task of being the voice of the law
or the arm of the law and to go out and
to treat people with respect and dignity
and and not be terrified at every
fucking traffic stop.
That's,
that's a big problem.
A big problem is also the problem with
the communities that we've allowed these
terribly disenfranchised in impoverished
communities to stay exactly the way they
are without pumping federal funds into
them without trying to clean them up
well without trying to figure out a way
to elevate people in these areas.
We want them to pull themselves up by
their bootstraps and without doing it
with gentrification,
without going in there because hey,
that's where the rent is currently cheap
and taking over those areas and forcing
out lower rent.
Families that can't make enough money is
like the housing.
That's like a sneaky thing that people
do like do,
do it,
but not all.
Not all just real estate people do it,
people do it like looking for apartment
buildings and all that.
It's like it's,
it's.
That's a very real thing and if more
people with more money move into an
area,
rents go higher,
it's this fucking statistical and then
those people that are on assisted
funding or people that have limited
access to funds because of jobs and all
that,
they get pushed out of those areas and
they create concentrated areas of very
low middle class to low class poverty,
food deserts,
horrible fucking places and everybody
just turns a fucking blind eye to it.
Well,
people are busy with their own lives.
That's really what it is.
Most people don't have the resources or
the wherewithal to do anything to have
an impact on these impoverished
communities and they have their own
credit card debt.
That's fine,
but they can at least understand that
that is going on that okay,
you understand and I understand that,
but how is that helping those people?
That's a very good question.
Give me a second so I don't sound like a
ranting idiot.
We understand.
First of all,
congratulations for taking a pause
because most people don't.
Most people,
they just keep plowing through.
They'll go,
well,
it was thinking about this shitting
shitting on Eric Dubay that that's just.
I know you're still angry.
I controlled you.
Totally,
totally.
I will get my revenge.
I knew this podcast.
Oh
my guy that's in my back pocket.
I'm going to have to break out that
video at one point in time on to watch
him watch you get fucking beat red and
we know that is true.
Is it affecting us?
Possibly.
Can it affect the human race as a whole
hundred percent?
Yes.
Because of that.
Because of the reach you have,
I don't nearly have the reach you have,
but because of the reach you have and
you have that reach right now,
I have that absolutely right now,
but this is like what?
Twice in two years.
Come on.
You do this fucking five times a week,
but the numbers that this podcast are
reaching comparison to the numbers have
reached two years ago.
Dude,
you gonna hit millions of people right
now.
Well then that's great what you're
saying.
Well then what they need to do is they
need to understand and yeah,
this isn't like,
you know,
a send money to Africa thing and all
that.
Yes,
there's horrible poverty,
poverty in the world.
There's horrible food shortages in the
world and all of that,
but you also have to think about what is
happening specifically in your
community.
We are one species.
We are Homo Sapiens,
sapiens.
It's our job because we are affecting
the planet to also fix because we live
here.
This is our current home.
This is the only one we have.
We have overpopulation problem.
We have food problems.
All of that.
Start small.
Fix Your fucking community by simply
saying hi to your neighbor.
If somebody is saying,
if you're in a crowded apartment
building and you know you have a person
like struggling with,
with groceries,
why not offer to fucking help because
then it takes get a word.
You're to rape her.
No,
you got to follow her into her apartment
and just to put them in the fucking
elevator and the put them out the of
something simple as that would be nice.
Yeah.
I have an idea how about people actually
bought or bother to merge correctly on
freeways or to not,
you know,
not cut people off at the last second,
think about what your actions are doing.
Think cognitively on what that is
happening,
what's causing that?
All of you motherfuckers that cut in at
the last time to get around traffic,
guess what?
You're causing the fucking traffic.
This is simple physics.
I don't think this is going to help poor
people,
but no,
but it's not,
but it's not on Jamie.
There's actually an article just came
out this week that says that that helps
traffic.
I don't know if it's.
It's probably a scientific study,
but people cutting people off helps
track cutting people off,
but the people that merging the last
second,
last,
mergers improve traffic.
How is that possible?
Because everyone thinks if mother
fuckers science,
it's impossible.
Everything backs up behind them.
You not.
If they're good,
they know what they're doing.
If they're a good band,
they got a little Miada or something
like that.
My challenge is 16 feet long car.
I love those cars right out there.
It was a fun trade,
you know,
need to know anyway,
but helping them sort of why I'm helping
in your community as simple.
So like the place I work right now,
the faculty,
we're a neighborhood bar.
We're nice to
people in the neighborhood we make.
We make deals with the local business
owners.
We talk about the neighborhood.
We try and drive crime out.
We try and do all that kind of thing.
My owner owns two shops on that block.
We're trying to revitalize the blog.
We're not trying to gentrify it.
We're not trying to like bring in the
hipsters from fucking silver lake and
all that bullshit.
Why it was wrong with the hipsters.
I don't get me started,
but they look like you.
They have like yellow beards and wear
weird clothes,
you know?
No tattoos.
I don't have skinny jeans.
Dude.
Come on.
Look at me.
You're a big fella.
I'm a big fellow fellow.
You might not have skinny jeans.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't do that.
I'm not doing that.
What's wrong with the hipsters?
I just,
I be.
It's,
it's the.
It's the pomposity of hipsters that
bothered me.
The word I love that you used pomposity
not all hipsters.
Hashtag,
Um,
Hashtag.
Yes.
All women.
Hashtag not all hipsters.
There are a select few that are the
stereotypical hipster of like,
Eh,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
you know,
I liked them before.
They were cool and shit like that.
Yeah.
They have vinyl and we listen to vinyl
in my car.
Fucking record player in their Prius
con.
Oh Wow.
That's a stupid fucking imagery.
How you know it's happened over.
There was a record player that they came
up with for cars in the 19 fifties,
I want to say that was EPA for speed.
Bumps were invented.
Now man.
I mean it didn't work,
but there was a record player for cars I
long fucking time ago.
I'm trying to remember.
Oh,
there it is.
Look at this.
Chrysler did eventually add an option to
play 45 rpm records on the high way high
five.
But perhaps that choice came too late in
1960.
A much cheaper car record player was
offered as a Chrysler option to come on
the market.
The RCA Victor Auto Victrola,
it costs $51.
It'd be $410 today and you can play your
own 40 fives on it.
Way to go.
Mopar,
yeah.
That's fucking.
Look at this thing.
That's awesome.
This is pretty fucking dope.
But you know,
obviously you got to drive real slow and
hit no bumps and father got super
annoying.
But look how it works man.
It's crazy.
That's bad ass.
You pick up the record player,
you slide it in there and it literally.
That's a stack.
It's an early CD changer.
Yeah.
He's got like,
that's what they used to do.
People don't remember that,
but yeah,
no,
the needles used to lift up and they
would take the next record and drop it
down and play the next one.
That was so cool back then.
We'd stack a bunch of records on top of
each other.
Better what it read off that if it's
reading the bottom,
the weight,
right?
Oh Hey.
Yeah.
Good idea.
And if there's any kind,
any kind of shock absorption there that
we'll and see if we can hear anything
that still does.
Now
61,
desoto,
that song makes you want to kill myself.
Some of that old music that reminds me
of like grandma's house like right
before she died.
I'm like,
oh,
it's depressing in here.
And on that note,
let's wrap this bitch up and bring it
home,
trevor.
Thank you brothers really more often
than every two years.
Absolutely.
It's like all those text messages back
and forth.
If we could do this all the time that we
can do this.
Dude,
I'm local.
Your local.
We can make this happen.
Yeah.
And next time when you're at the place
across the street from where I am.
Come the fuck over.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That was at the Baja cafe and I was a
Tiki.
Know what's Tiki?
Tiki knows a bad ass Tiki bar in north
Hollywood right there on like a lot of
bars fellow,
Huh?
Kind of a boozer.
A little bit and a little bit
functional.
Alcoholic.
Cheers.
Cheers on that.
Thank you again.
And Tattoos and bones on twitter,
if you want to yell at them for being a
flat earth shell or round Earth Shell,
rather,
people are already doing it.
They're like,
you should call him out on his fatness.
He's not healthy.
Stuff like that.
I don't read that out loud for sure.
Are you feeding the trolls?
Oh yeah,
they have data.
Hey,
nick steroid,
David Jennings.
Fuck you.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with Duncan
trussell.
See it.